Thank you for listening to the rest is history for weekly bonus episodes, ad free listening, early access to series and membership of our much loved chat community. Go to the rest is history.com and join the club that is the rest is history.com. So Tom, we've got some absolutely thrilling news for our listeners down under, don't we? We do Dominic, because of course this autumn sees England going to Australia to lose the ashes, but they're not the only group of Englishmen who will be heading to Australia because we are going there in November and December this year. So we will be playing five tests.
感谢收听《历史余音》的每周独家节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先收听以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区。访问 therestishistory.com，加入这个由 therestishistory.com 打造的俱乐部。那么，汤姆，我们对于远在南半球的听众们可是有一个绝对令人振奋的消息，对吧？确实是这样，多米尼克，因为今年秋天英格兰当然要去澳大利亚争夺骨灰杯，但他们并不是唯一前往澳大利亚的英格兰人，因为今年十一月和十二月我们要去那里。所以我们将进行五场测试赛。
We'll be doing five shows in front of our beloved Australian audience. So in late November, we will be doing two shows in Sydney, including one of the Opera House, and we'll be doing a show in Melbourne. And then the beginning of December, we will be doing shows in Adelaide and in Brisbane. We've got some fantastic shows lined up for you, very possibly featuring one of Australia's greatest exports, but we will draw a veil over that for now. Tickets will be on sale exclusively to our beloved members of the Rest is History Club
我们将在我们热爱的澳大利亚观众面前进行五场演出。因此在十一月下旬，我们将在悉尼进行两场演出，其中包括一场在悉尼歌剧院的演出，我们还将在墨尔本进行一场演出。然后十二月初，我们将在阿德莱德和布里斯班进行演出。我们为您筹备了一些非常精彩的演出，极有可能邀请到澳大利亚最伟大的出口成果之一，但我们目前对此先保密。门票将独家向我们热爱的“历史余音俱乐部”会员发售。
from next Monday, that's the 30th of June at 11 a.m. Australian Eastern Standard Time. So join the Rest is History Club at therestishistory.com now if you want to snap your tickets up early. And tickets will then be available to purchase for everyone else at therestishistory.com from next Thursday that's the 3rd of July again at 11 a.m. Australian Eastern Standard Time. So for your chance to see us on stage live in an Australian city near you, just head to therestishistory.com to get your tickets.
从下周一，也就是 6 月 30 日上午 11 点（澳大利亚东部标准时间）开始。因此，如果您想早点抢到门票，现在就去 therestishistory.com 加入“历史余音俱乐部”吧。随后，门票将于下周四，即 7 月 3 日上午 11 点（同样为澳大利亚东部标准时间）起，在 therestishistory.com 向所有人公开销售。因此，想要在您附近的澳大利亚城市现场观看我们的演出，只需前往 therestishistory.com 购票即可。
Whether it's a family member, friend or furry companion joining your summer road trip, enjoy the peace of mind that comes with Volvo's legendary safety. During Volvo Discover Days, enjoy limited time savings as you make plans to cruise through Muskoka or down Toronto's bustling streets. From now until June 30th, lease a 2025 Volvo XC60 from 1.74% and save up to $4,000.ca for full details. Let me carry your cross for Ireland, Lord. The hour of her trial draws near, and the pangs and the pains of the sacrifice may be borne by comrades dear.
无论是家庭成员、朋友还是毛茸茸的同伴加入您的夏季公路旅行，都能享受沃尔沃传奇安全性能带来的安心。在沃尔沃探索日期间，当您计划在马斯科卡或穿梭于多伦多繁华街道时，即可享受限时优惠。即日起至 6 月 30 日，租赁 2025 款沃尔沃 XC60 利率低至 1.74%，最高可省 4,000 美元。访问 .ca 了解完整详情。主啊，让我为爱尔兰背负你的十字架吧。她受审的时刻临近，牺牲的阵痛与悲伤也许正由亲爱的战友们承载。
Let me carry your cross for Ireland Lord, let me suffer the pain and shame, I bow my head to their rage and hate and I take on myself the blame. Let them do with my body whatever they will, my spirit I offer to you, that the faithful few who heard our call may be spared to Roisin do. Let me carry your cross for Ireland, Lord, for Ireland weak with tears, for the aged man of the clouded brow and the child of tender years, for the empty homes of her golden plains, for the hopes of her future too.
主啊，让我为爱尔兰背负你的十字架，让我承受痛苦与羞辱，我向他们的愤怒与仇恨低下头颅，将罪责一肩挑起。任凭他们如何处置我的躯体，我将灵魂献予你，愿我们听到召唤而来的忠诚信徒们，能够免于劫难，留待繁荣的爱尔兰。主啊，让我为爱尔兰背负你的十字架，为了饱含泪水的爱尔兰，为了饱经风霜的老人与年幼的孩子，为了她金色平原上空无一人的家园，也为了她未来的希望。
Let me carry your cross for Ireland, Lord, for the cause of Roisin Do. So that was the Irish revolutionary Thomas Ash. And he wrote that poem when he was in Lewis Prison in Sussex in 1917 and Roisin Dou, by the way, is Ireland. So Ash was a farmer's son from County Kerry. He was a teacher, he was a school principal, he became an Irish language activist before the First World War, great activist in Irish sport as well, set up a local branch of the
主啊，让我为爱尔兰背负你的十字架，为了繁荣的爱尔兰的事业。刚才那是爱尔兰革命者托马斯·阿什。他在 1917 年身处萨塞克斯郡的刘易斯监狱时写下了这首诗，顺便说一句，“Roisin Dubh”就是爱尔兰的意思。所以阿什是来自凯里郡的一个农夫的儿子。他曾是一名教师、一名校长，在第一次世界大战前成为了一名爱尔兰语活动家，同时也是爱尔兰体育界的一位伟大活动家，创办了当地的分支机构……
Gaelic Athletic Association. And he joins the Irish Volunteers, a paramilitary group in 1913, and then was a key figure in the Easter Rising three years later, fighting a five-hour battle against the Royal Irish Constabulary. He was arrested, he was court-martialed, he was sentenced to death, but his sentence was commuted and then he was released after he'd written that poem. And then in 1917, I mean, growing tension in Ireland, he was arrested again and he went
盖尔运动协会。他在 1913 年加入了爱尔兰志愿军这一准军事组织，三年后成为了复活节起义的关键人物，与皇家爱尔兰警察局进行了长达五个小时的战斗。他被捕了，上了军事法庭，被判处死刑，但他的刑罚被减免了，在写完那首诗后他被释放了。然后在 1917 年，我的意思是，随着爱尔兰紧张局势的加剧，他再次被捕，并进行了……
on hunger strike. And Tom will find out how that story played out a little bit later, won't we? Yeah, we will. And this is the first of a three-part series about the Irish independence struggle between 1916, so the year of the Easter Rising, and 1921, which sees a truce established after a period of war between the British state and Irish revolutionaries. There is then a treaty drawn up between Britain
绝食抗议。汤姆，我们稍后会了解到这个故事是如何发展的，对吧？是的，我们会了解的。这是关于 1916 年（即复活节起义之年）至 1921 年（英国国家与爱尔兰革命者之间爆发战争并经历一段时间后达成停战协议）期间爱尔兰独立斗争的三集系列节目的第一集。随后，英国与……之间起草了一份条约。
and what will become the Free State that grants Ireland limited independence and effectively creates Northern Ireland. And then we'll be looking at the bitter civil war that tore Ireland apart in 1922 and 1923. So that'll be two episodes on that. And that story is bookended by two assassinations. The first of those, the British and indeed Irish Field
后来成为自由邦的国家，这赋予了爱尔兰有限的独立，实际上也创建了北爱尔兰。接着，我们将探讨在 1922 年和 1923 年把爱尔兰撕裂的惨烈内战。那将有两集节目来讲述这段历史。这个故事由两次暗杀首尾呼应。第一次暗杀的目标是英国以及爱尔兰的陆军……
Marshal Sir Henry Wilson and the Irish National Commander in Chief Michael Collins. But before we get to this extraordinary story, gripping story, we should say where we are because we did a previous episode didn't we on the Easter Rising and we were in the GPO for that perfect setting and here we are in the Auguste en Veyron of the Royal Irish Academy in the heart of Dublin. It contains absolute treasures of old Irish literature going all the way back to the sixth century and of course the the Gaelic revival, the fascination of Irish people in the 19th and early 20th century with their early history is a crucial part of the story
元帅亨利·威尔逊爵士，以及爱尔兰国家总司令迈克尔·柯林斯。但在我们进入这个非凡的故事、扣人心弦的故事之前，我们应该说说我们现在在哪里，因为我们之前做过一集关于复活节起义的节目，当时我们在总邮局，那是完美的背景，而现在我们在位于都柏林市中心的皇家爱尔兰科学院的奥古斯特·昂维隆。这里藏有可以追溯到公元 6 世纪的古爱尔兰文学的绝对珍宝，当然还有盖尔复兴运动，19世纪和 20 世纪初爱尔兰人对其早期历史的着迷，这是我们……
that we'll be telling. But it was also established, the clue is in the title Royal Irish Academy by George III, and so there is a reminder there of how deep the British roots in Irish history are as well. Absolutely, and we're here thanks to our guest today. So a great friend of The Rest Is History, well known as the former caretaker manager of County Offaly, professor of history at University College Dublin, Irish national treasure, Paul Rouse. Oh dear. Paul, I know you hate being called a national treasure. And Paul, it was you, wasn't it, who read that poem. It wasn't Dominic or me.
将要讲述的故事的至关重要的一部分。但它也是由乔治三世建立的，线索就在“皇家爱尔兰科学院”这个名字里，所以这也提醒了我们，英国在爱尔兰历史上的根基有多么深厚。绝对是这样，我们今天能来到这里要感谢我们的嘉宾。作为《历史余音》的老朋友，人们熟知他是奥法利郡前看守主教练、都柏林大学学院历史学教授、爱尔兰国宝保罗·劳斯。哦天哪。保罗，我知道你讨厌被称为国宝。保罗，就是你读的那首诗，对吧？不是多米尼克，也不是我。
It was. Doing an impression of Thomas Ash. No, that was me. So Paul, you joined us a couple of years ago and you took us through a mighty sweep. You covered all Irish history up to 1916. We reached at the end of that amid the rubble of the Easter Rising. And before we get into what happens next, maybe we should remind newer listeners of the broader context, because a really important thing for a lot of the Irish revolutionaries is this idea that they have suffered 800 years of British oppression.
正是如此。模仿托马斯·阿什。不，那是我。所以保罗，你几年前加入我们，带我们纵览了一段宏大的历史。你涵盖了截至 1916 年的所有爱尔兰历史。我们在复活节起义的废墟之中迎来了那段历史的结束。在我们深入探讨接下来发生的事情之前，也许我们应该向新听众提醒一下更广阔的背景，因为对许多爱尔兰革命者来说，一个非常重要的观点是，他们认为自己遭受了英国长达 800 年的压迫。
And is that fair or is the truth a bit more complicated? It's a bit more complicated, but you'll amaze me. That war cry of 800 years of oppression was particularly bandied about with the start of modern troubles in Northern Ireland in 1969 because there's a really nice symmetry in numerous terms back to 1169 with the arrival of Strongbow followed two years later by King John and the establishment of an English lordship in Ireland. So there is a certain logic to that cry, but we know of course that modern notions of the
这公平吗，还是说真相要复杂得多？情况要复杂得多，但你会让我感到惊讶。1969 年北爱尔兰现代动乱爆发时，那种“被压迫 800 年”的战斗口号被到处宣扬，因为在许多方面，它与 1169 年强弓理查登陆、两年后约翰国王到来并在爱尔兰建立英国领地有着非常美妙的对称性。因此，这种口号有一定的逻辑性，但我们当然知道，现代民族国家的概念并不能轻易地套用到过去的几个世纪里。然而，对我们而言重要的是，领地确实存在，但在 16 世纪之前一直受到限制。所以在都柏林周围有一个区域，即英国海关区内，它是领地的一部分。然后在全国各地，你拥有盎格鲁-爱尔兰人或英国人（取决于人们希望给他们冠以什么头衔），即庞大的土地所有者。然后你还有盎格鲁-爱尔兰人或英国人，取决于人们希望给他们冠以什么头衔，庞大的土地所有者，接着你还有盖尔人酋长，在 1600 年代之前的爱尔兰，所有这些都交织在一个斑驳的世界里。然后在国王亨利八世统治下一切都变了，他着手通过战争、外交、恩惠以及基本上通过庇护来征服爱尔兰。当然，这种征服并没有被国王在这里的敌人所接受，而且……
nation state do not easily apply back across the centuries. But what matters for our purposes is that the Lordship existed, but was restricted until the 16th century. So you had an area around Dublin, the inside the Pail, which was part of the Lordship. Around the country, then you had Anglo-Irish or English, depending on what title people wish to put on them, massive landowners. And then you had Anglo-Irish or English, depending on what title people wished to put on them, massive landowners, and then you had Gaelic chieftains, all interspersed in a kind of a speckled world of Ireland before the 1600s. Everything then changed under King Henry VIII, who said about conquest of Ireland through war, through diplomacy, through favour, patronage, basically. And of course, that conquest was not accepted by the king's enemies here and
爱尔兰敌人进行了反击。但在接下来的的一百年里，你迎来了新因素的引入，那就是宗教。由于宗教改革，宗教紧密相连，这改变了宗教面貌，它导致了爱尔兰大片土地（在阿尔斯特、芒斯特以及最初的莱伊什-奥法利）被忠诚的清教徒殖民，土地从以前耕种它们的人手中被夺走。当然，这样做的结果是将宗教与土地、权力和社会地位捆绑在了一起。
the Irish enemies fought back. But over the period of the following hundred years, you have the introduction of a new factor, that is religion. And religion is tied because of the Reformation, a kind of a changed religious landscape, And it led to the plantation of large swades of Ireland in Ulster and Munster and initially in Leigh-Shawfley of loyal Protestants and the land been taking from people who had previously farmed it. And what this did, of course, was tie religion to land and power and place within society.
因此，你得到的是一个极其复杂的社会，其中有时存在宽容甚至善意，但也存在恐惧和厌恶。在 1640 年代发生了大屠杀，天主教徒屠杀了大约 4,000 名新教徒。然后克伦威尔来了，当他离开或者他的军队离开时，五分之一的人口已经死亡。所以宗教一次又一次地像绞杀植物一样缠绕在爱尔兰社会的本质周围，它塑造了爱尔兰生活的方方面面。但到了 1700 年代，“新教徒和忠诚者对阵天主教徒和反叛者”成了略带漫画色彩的历史版本。
So what you get is an extraordinary complex society where there is tolerance and even goodwill at times, but there's also fear and loathing. And there were massacres in the 1640s where Catholics massacred probably 4,000 Protestants. And then you have Cromwell who arrives and by the time he leaves, or his armies leave, there is one fifth of the population dead. So it's time and again religion had wrapped itself like bindweed around the nature of Irish society and it shaped every aspect of life in Ireland. But by the 1700s, Protestant and loyal versus Catholic and rebellious is the slightly cartoonish version of history.
但对我们而言，当我们来到 1800 年或 1790 年代末时，情况就是这样。没错。然后在 1800 年，情况发生了变化，通过了《联合法案》，爱尔兰与大不列颠合并为一个联合王国。是的。在 1798 年起义之后，这场起义受到美国和法国共和国思想的推动，并将这种共和主义思想输入爱尔兰以契合当地情况。现在同样，在 1790 年代，宗教的分裂实际上更加复杂，但最终那场起义导致了 1800 年《联合法案》的通过。因此，这就是为什么天主教身份开始与共和主义理念联系在一起。
But it's for our purposes, by the time we get to 1800 or the late 1790s, that's where we are. Right. And then in 1800, it changes, there's the Act of Union, and Ireland becomes part of a united kingdom with Great Britain. Yes. In the wake of a rebellion of 1798, which had been driven by ideas of the republics of America and of France and imported this idea of republicanism into Ireland to fit around. Now again, the divides of religion are really more complex in the 1790s, but ultimately that rebellion leads to the passage of an active union in 1800. And so that's why Catholic identity comes to be associated with the idea of republicanism.
它要追溯到法国大革命时期。它从那个时期一直延续到现在，我们将在接下来的节目中看到这一点。这并不是一种对革命的教条式的意识形态承诺。它不是王室，也不是英国王室。它是大多数人的驱动力。是一种与众不同的感觉。然而，即便在这个单一国家中，所谓的单一国家里，爱尔兰，它是大不列颠及爱尔兰联合王国。所以爱尔兰并不是英国的一部分。
It's dating to the period of the French Revolution. It comes from that period onwards and we will see this as we go through it. It's not a kind of a doctrinaire ideological commitment to revolution. It's not a crown and it's not the British crown. It's a driving force for the majority of people. It's the sense of it being different. And even in this unitary state though, supposed unitary state, Ireland, it was the United Kingdom of Great Britain and Ireland. So Ireland was not part of Britain.
是的。这是我们在接下来的过程中需要记住的一个非常重要的点。在 19 世纪，可能有一些我们需要讨论的关键决定性事件。首先是 1840 年代发生了饥荒，如果不计具体数字的话，这场饥荒导致了一百万人死亡，一百万人移民。我知道你们在全美有很多听众。他们中的许多人将是那些在饥荒期间及其之后离开的人的后代。但保罗，爱尔兰人也在向英国移民。所以这也是我们将要讲述的故事至关重要的一部分……
Yeah. And that's a really important point to remember as we move through this. And there are probably key defining things that we need to talk about in the 19th century. The first is the fact that there was famine in the 1840s and that famine left, if we go around numbers, a million people dead and a million people emigrated. I know you've a lot of listeners across America. Many of them will be descended from people who left during the famine and in its aftermath. But Paul, also Irish people are emigrating to Britain. And so that is also a crucial
一部分，即有许多在英国长大的爱尔兰人，他们的身份认同也存在冲突。是的，在爱尔兰显现的分裂尤其可以在利物浦等地看到，当丹·杰克逊之前和你做节目时，在他的书中对这些分裂的本质进行了精彩的阐述。你沿着伦敦的托特纳姆法院路走去，那些地方都被重塑了。我们将会在故事中遇到在伦敦度过时光的重要人物。哦，他们对这个故事非常重要。所以饥荒留下了这种遗产，这种巨大的创伤，而在 19 世纪末，你迎来了盖尔复兴运动以及一种……
part of the story we'll be telling that there are lots of Irish people growing up in Britain whose identity is conflicted as well. Yeah, and the divides that manifest themselves in Ireland can be seen in places like Liverpool in particular and Dan Jackson when he was on with you previously did this brilliantly in his book is wonderful on the nature of those divides. And you go along the Tottenham Court Road in London, it's remade in those places. And we will be meeting significant players in the story who have spent time in London. Oh, they're really important to the story. So The Famine leaves this sort of legacy, this tremendous trauma, and in the late 19th century you have the Gaelic Revival and a kind of,
你会说这是爱尔兰民族主义的复兴还是发明？所以饥荒，首先，它之所以重要，是因为它对爱尔兰民族主义产生的影响，但它对于在美国建立的移民社区也很重要。我们将看到他们如何为革命提供资金并使其人员饱满，最终我们将从其发明和创造的角度来谈论这场革命。其中有些部分完全是发明出来的。是的。有些部分完全是发明出来的。而且有一些故事是编造出来的，但其中存在的是一种觉醒。你刚才在这里看到了，你提到了那些手稿以及……
is it a revival or an invention of Irish nationalism, would you say? So the famine, first of all, it's important because of the impact it had on Irish nationalism, but it's also important for the emigre communities that are created in America. And we will see how they have to fund and people the revolution, which ultimately we will end up talking about in terms of its invention and its creation. There are parts of it which are entirely invented. Yeah. And there are parts of it which are entirely invented. And there are stories made up, but what there is is a reawakening. You saw earlier here, you mentioned the manuscripts that are there and the annals of the Four Masters that are
皇家爱尔兰科学院藏有的《四大师年鉴》。你在 19 世纪所拥有的，是对这些文献的重新发现、将其翻译成现代语言以及爱尔兰神话和传奇的普遍普及。你拥有对爱尔兰语兴趣的重新觉醒。你拥有一个日常游戏的替代体育世界的创造。但是我的天，这个地方太迷人了，不是吗？因为它是皇家……你知道，你的头衔里有“皇家”这个词，但它正在为古代爱尔兰产生所有的这种激情和热情。
here in the Royal Irish Academy. What you had in the 19th century was a rediscovery of these, a translation of them into modern language and a general popularization of Irish myths and sagas. You have a reawakening of interest in the Irish language. You have a creation of an alternative sporting world of daily games. But I mean, this place is fascinating, isn't it? Because it's the royal, you know, you have the royal in the title, but it is generating all this passion and enthusiasm for ancient Ireland.
而其中的许多关键人物实际上都是新教徒。所以在这一点上，它并不是一种二元对立。不，这不是二元对立，但是，当我们谈到帝国和帝国战争时，我们倾向于想象这是一个相当简单的叙事，有着清晰的阵营。但当然，生活的现实远比那要复杂得多。
And a lot of the key figures in this are actually Protestant. So at this point, it's not a kind of binary. No, it's not a binary, but it's, we again, when it comes to empire and it comes to imperial war, we like to imagine that this is a fairly straightforward narrative with clear sides. But of course, the reality of life is way more complex than that.
所以说到复杂性，让我们来到 1900 年代和 1910 年代至关重要的几年，我们在上一系列节目中讲过这些。我知道这是一个很大的要求，保罗，但你能在大约三分钟内解释一下，为什么地方自治危机——也就是英国和爱尔兰关于是否授予爱尔兰地方自治权（基本上是在赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯的自由党政府下建立自己的议会）的一场巨大争端——为什么这会对爱尔兰政治产生如此有毒的影响，以及为什么它会导致这种新型的准军事政治？
So talking about complexities, let's come to the crucial years of the 1900s and 1910s, which we did in the last series. I know this is a big ask, Paul, but are you able in like three minutes to explain why the Home Rule crisis, so this is a huge argument in Britain and Ireland about whether Ireland will be granted a Home Rule, basically its own parliament under the Liberal government of Herbert Henry Asquith. And why does that have such a toxic effect on politics in Ireland and why does it lead to this new kind of paramilitary politics?
它在英国和爱尔兰引发了一场巨大的危机，因为你把时间倒回几年，比如 1872 年，托利党领袖索尔兹伯里勋爵说，爱尔兰必须像印度一样，作为帝国的一部分被保留下来，如果不是通过说服，就要通过武力。所以在 1880 年代，首先爆发了一场土地战争，当时爱尔兰的土地掌握在 5,000 到 7,000 个家族手中。并且展开了一场激烈的斗争……
It leads to an enormous crisis in Britain and in Ireland because you step back here a few years, so you'd Lord Salisbury, the Tory leader in 1872, saying that Ireland, like India, must be kept as part of the empire, if not by persuasion, then by force. So in the 1880s, there was a land war, first of all, waged where the land of Ireland was held by between five and 7,000 families. And there was a massive struggle
在普通爱尔兰人中间为了索取土地而进行的斗争。它导致了在不同地区和不同地方交织在一起的愤怒与消极抵抗。这导致了对差异的认识不断增强。所以这不仅仅是不同国籍的概念。这是一种生活经历，它正在造成分裂。在此期间，自由党领袖格莱斯顿表示，他的使命是安抚爱尔兰。
amongst ordinary Irish people to claim that land. And it led to both outrage and passive resistance mixed in different parts and different places. And that led to a growing sense of difference. So this is not just the idea of a different nationality. This is a lived experience, which is creating divide. And within that, Gladstone, leader of the Liberal Party, has said that his mission is to pacify Ireland.
他认为实现这一目标的方法是授予某种形式的地方自治议会。但不是独立。我的意思是，那是关键点。此时没有人谈论独立。嗯，爱尔兰民族主义中确实有人希望独立。他们是爱尔兰共和兄弟会，他们在秘密武装，秘密进行军事训练，成立于 1858 年，并在 1867 年发动了一场起义。绝大多数民众看不到任何出路，即使他们希望独立，但大英帝国是世界上最强大的帝国。它的……
And the way he sees that this can be done is to grant a sort of a home rule parliament. But not independence. I mean, that's the crucial thing. No one at this point is talking about independence. Well, there are people in Irish nationalism who wish for independence. They're the Irish Republican Brotherhood who are secretly arming, secretly drilling, founded in 1858, stage a rebellion in 1867. The great swathe of the population can see no way, even if they wish for independence, the British Empire is the most mighty empire in the world. It's
它的权力和特权以及商业和文化的声望，连同军事力量，无处不在。而一小群爱尔兰叛军要击败他们的想法看起来荒谬绝伦。所以他们妥协了。他们接受了地方自治议会的想法。其构想是，将相当大的一部分权力——不，我不会说相当大，我会说相当可观的权力——下放给一个都柏林议会，而该议会最终仍将效忠于伦敦的帝国议会。而且没有任何迹象表明维多利亚女王也将不会成为爱尔兰女王。其中一个巨大问题是岛屿东北部的人们，特别是岛屿东北部的人们……
its power and its privilege and its prestige of both commerce and culture, as well as military might, it sits everywhere. And the idea that a group of Irish rebels are going to beat them seems ridiculous. So they settle. They settle for the idea of a Home Rule Parliament. And the idea is that a significant, no, I won't say significant, I will say a considerable amount of power will be devolved to a parliament in Dublin, which will ultimately owe its allegiance though to the Imperial Parliament in London. And there is no suggestion that Queen Victoria will not also be Queen of Ireland. And a huge issue in this is the people in the northeast of the, in particular in the northeast of the island,
但实际上也散布在岛上的其他地方，他们不想要这个，通常因为他们是新教徒，他们认为，好吧，那只意味着我将生活在天主教地方自治议会的某种暴政之下，我不希望这样，这特别与阿尔斯特省有关，阿尔斯特省的总人口在爱尔兰的比例大约是 30%？你看到的是 30% 的效忠比例。所以这可以包括一些效忠于……或者对帝国感到非常……的中产阶级天主教徒等。
but actually also scattered elsewhere in the island, who don't want that, often because they're Protestants, and they think, well that would just mean I'd be living under the sort of the tyranny of a Catholic Home-rule Parliament, and I don't want that and this is particularly associated with Ulster with the province of Ulster the total population in Ireland that the proportion of that is about 30% you're looking at 30% allegiance So that can include some middle-class Catholics, etc Who owe their allegiance to, or who are more
对帝国感到非常自在。丝毫没有对这一前景感到惊慌的感觉。我认为，多米尼克，这也是很重要的，不仅仅是因为他们由于精神或宗教原因而害怕天主教统治。贝尔法斯特是一个与众不同的地方。贝尔法斯特是爱尔兰唯一真正实现工业化的地区。贝尔法斯特的人口从 1810 年的大约 1.6 万人，在造船业和亚麻工业的推动下，到 20 世纪初增长到了 35 万人。这里是泰坦尼克号的故乡。正是如此。所有这一切对于围绕贝尔法斯特创造一种不同的文化都非常重要。而这种文化认为，它对帝国的繁荣以及宗教自由和其他自由负有责任。
than comfortable with an empire. No sense that they are dismayed by the prospect. And that matters as well, I think, Dominic, in that it's not just that they fear papish rule because of spiritual or religious reasons. Belfast is a place apart. Belfast is the one part of Ireland that is truly industrialized. Belfast grew from 16,000 people in 1810 more or less to 350,000 by the early 1900s driven by the shipyards and the linen industries. It's the home of Titanic. Exactly. And it's all of that is really important to creating a different culture around Belfast. And that culture believes that it owes prosperity as well as religious freedom and other freedoms to the empire.
是的。所以在 1880 年，英国托利党领导或协助了工会主义者的反对行动，张伯伦在那里打出了著名的“橙色牌”，也就是这个想法：我们给予工会主义者支持，这基本上导致了 1880 年代《地方自治法案》的夭折。所以它没有通过。它在 1892 年也没有通过，在 1890 年代又有了一次努力，然后它看起来一直处于沉寂状态，直到 1909 年到 1911 年间英国政治的一场剧变改变了……
Yeah. And so in 1880, opposition from Unionists led or assisted by the Tory party in England, where Chamberlain played the orange card famously, this idea that we give support to Unionists, and it basically collapsed the Home Rule Bill in the 1880s. So it wasn't passed. It wasn't passed again in 1892, in the Home Rule Bill in the 1880s. So it wasn't passed. It wasn't passed again in 1892, in the 1890s when there was another effort, and then it looked like it was dormant until an upheaval in British politics between 1909 and 1911 transformed the
政治格局。是的，我们在第一系列的节目中做过几期关于这个话题的节目，如果人们想要了解所有的复杂情况，可以回去听听。但实际上你所拥有的是，自由党政府想要给予地方自治，但特别是阿尔斯特的工会主义者不想要。他们开始武装自己，所以你开始有了准军事政治，比如阿尔斯特志愿军，然后你也有赞成地方自治的爱尔兰志愿军在武装自己，所以你有一种……你知道，爱尔兰政治有一种滑向武装对抗的感觉，然后这在 1914 年被萨拉热窝的枪声和第一次世界大战的爆发打断了。现在地方自治法案在这一点上已经通过了，所以地方自治将被授予，大家是这么认为的……
political landscape. Yeah, and we did a couple of episodes on this in the first series so people can go back and listen to it if they want all the complexities But effectively what you have is the liberal government want to give home rule But the unionists particularly in ulster don't want it They start to arm so you start to have paramilitary politics kind of the ulster volunteers and then you also have the irish volunteers arming who are in favor of home rule, so you have a sort of You know, there's a sense in which Irish politics is slipping towards armed confrontation, and then that is interrupted in 1914 by the shootings in Sarajevo and the outbreak of the First World War. Now the Home Rule Bill at this point has been passed, so Home Rule will be granted, that is the thought,
但整个事情基本上被第一次世界大战的爆发给冻结了，不是吗？所以它并没有消失，只是处于休眠状态。是这样吗？是的，确实如此。我认为向多米尼克你强调这一点非常重要，即从 1913 年到 1914 年武器的输入、阿尔斯特志愿军的建立，以及如果坚持给予爱尔兰地方自治权就为阿尔斯特建立临时政府的计划。这对于爱尔兰的军事化来说是一个非常重要的故事。而且在英国军队中甚至在托利党中确实有人在暗中勾结。嗯，普遍的看法是，保守党领袖知道这些……
but the whole thing is basically frozen, isn't it, by the outbreak of the First World War. So it doesn't go away, it's just dormant. Is that right? Yes, it is. I think it's really important for us Dominic to stress the importation of arms through 1913 into 1914, the establishment of the Ulster Volunteer Force and the plans to establish provisional government for Ulster if it was insisted upon that there should be Home Rule granted to Ireland. That's a really important story in the militarisation of Ireland. And there are people in the British Army and indeed in the Tory party who are effectively colluding. Well, the great belief is that the leader of the Conservative party knew that these
武器正在被输入，并且在说，阿尔斯特工会主义者无论采取什么程度的行动，我都无法想象有什么是我不会支持他们的。因此，这必定会破坏天主教徒对英国机构中立性的信心，而军队将是最明显的机构。而它所做的事情也激发了爱尔兰志愿军对枪支的输入。所以现在岛上有了第二支军事化的军队，而第三支军队也存在，那就是在都柏林拥有枪支的社会主义者公民军。所以他们也一心……
arms were being imported and was saying that there is no level that I can imagine that Ulster Unionists will go to that I will not support them. And so that must destabilise Catholic faith in the neutrality of British institutions, of which the army would be the most obvious. And what it does as well is it inspires the importation of guns by the Irish Volunteer Force. So now you have a second militarised army on the island and the third one exists where there is a citizen army of socialists who have guns in Dublin as well. So who are also bent
最终图谋叛乱。我想我们在上一系列的结尾时，阿斯奎斯曾说“感谢上帝爆发了第一次世界大战”。基本上，我转述一下，它不可能像一场走运一样糟糕。是的，战争爆发了，现在回想起来，由于战争持续的时间那么长以及随之而来的工业化大屠杀，这看起来更糟糕了。但危机如此深重，似乎难以解决，因为你拥有爱尔兰民族主义者，他们除了整个岛屿都在一个地方自治议会管辖之下外，什么都不接受；而爱尔兰工会主义者则说，我们不会加入一个地方自治议会。除了威斯敏斯特的统治，我们什么都不想要。是的。然后它似乎处于休眠状态。
on rebellion ultimately. I think we finished the last series by asking with saying thank God for the First World War. Basically, I paraphrase it can't be as bad as a stroke of luck. Yeah, war broke out in now that looks worse in hindsight because of because of the war lasting as long as it did and the industrial slaughter that ensued. But the crisis was so deep that it seemed intractable because you had Irish nationalists who would not accept anything other than the entire island under a home rule parliament and Irish Unionists saying, we're not going into a home rule parliament. We want nothing other than rule from Westminster. Yeah. And then so it appears to be dormant.
然后在 1916 年的复活节，冲突随着复活节起义而爆发，当时英国军队很快就平息了这场起义。我的意思是，都柏林的许多地方基本上化为废墟，但英国人能够将其扑灭，我想英国人得到的印象是：这发生得太烦人了。在我们在西线与德国人作战的时候，这算是一种背叛。然而……
And then at Easter 1916, the conflict flares into life with the Easter Rising Which actually at the time is very quickly put down by British forces I mean a lot of Dublin is sort of reduced to rubble But the British are able to stamp it out and the British I guess get the impression. It's very annoying that this has happened It's a sort of it's a betrayal at the time when we're fighting the Germans on the Western Front. However It's a sort of it's a betrayal at the time when we're fighting the Germans on the Western Front. However, Hopefully it's not going to prove a massive deal and what turns the Easter Rising into such a big deal? I first of all think that everybody says it's the executions. Yeah, that turned everything So basically after the rising the people who were involved it was about a thousand went out on Easter Monday
在我们在西线与德国人作战的时候，这算是一种背叛。然而，希望这不会被证明是一件大事，是什么让复活节起义变成了一件如此重要的大事？我首先认为每个人都说是处决。是的，是处决扭转了一切。所以基本上在起义之后，参与的人——复活节星期一那天大约有一千人出动。
By Easter Saturday by the time it ended there were were probably fifteen, sixteen hundred who had been on the streets. It was a really small minority of people who had struck during the war because it presented the opportunity, as they saw it, to rise and drag the people with it. So England's difficulty is Ireland's opportunity. Exactly. In the old saw. And that is not what happened, of course. And it was crushed within a very short space of time. And people said at the time that the rebels were mocked and abused on the streets
到复活节星期六结束时，街上可能已经有了一千五百、一千六百人。在战争期间发动起义的只是一小撮人，因为在他们看来，这提供了一个起义并拖拽人民一起前进的机会。所以英国的困难就是爱尔兰的机遇。正是如此。正如老话所说。当然，事情并没有那样发展。而且它在很短的时间内就被镇压了。当时有人说，叛军在街上遭到嘲笑和虐待……
and that there was incredible resistance to what they'd done and just disgust, actually. I think that's overplayed. Yes, there was some of that, but there were also other people who were, you know, admired them for what they were doing. Yeah. So, I mean, it's commonly said, isn't it, at the Easter Rising, that at the time they're a minority and actually people are horrified by it. And the British think, well, it's not going to be that big a deal. It's annoying. It's a bit of a betrayal at the time of fighting the Germans on the Western Front. But of course, it does turn out to be a landmark moment. And so what changes? What makes it so iconic?
而且人们对他们所做的事情有着难以置信的抵触情绪，甚至感到厌恶。我认为这被夸大了。是的，确实有那种情况，但也有其他人，你知道的，钦佩他们所做的事情。是的。所以，我的意思是，人们普遍认为，在复活节起义时，他们是少数派，实际上人们对此感到惊恐。英国人认为，好吧，这不会是什么大不了的事。这很烦人。在与西线德国人作战的时候，这有点像是一种背叛。但当然，这最终被证明是一个具有里程碑意义的时刻。那么是什么改变了？是什么让它如此具有标志性？
So it was, first of all, a minority and the scale of the minority is extraordinarily significant. It's about a thousand people went out on Easter Monday, maybe joined by a few hundred more as the week went along, but it's not a mass uprising. And I think when it comes down to it, there are a series of factors which change perceptions of people as to why people had reacted adversely to it in the city initially during the rising, although I do believe that that's somewhat overplayed and it hangs initially on the executions of the leaders. Now the leaders themselves, it should be said, expected to die on the week. They knew they were rising in time of war.
所以它首先是一个少数派，而少数派的规模是非常显著的。复活节星期一大约有一千人出动，随着一周的发展可能加入了几百人，但这不是一场大规模起义。我认为归根结底，有一系列因素改变了人们的看法，即起义期间城里的人最初为什么对它做出不利的反应，尽管我相信这在一定程度上被夸大了，而最初这一切都取决于对领袖们的处决。应该说，领袖们自己在那周就预计自己会死。他们知道他们是在战争时期起义的。
This was their opportunity. And this is the whole key to it being Easter. It's a sacrifice. And the word blood sacrifice is appended to this time and again. But so there are 187 people who rose court martial. The rest are put in pens around the place and are ultimately interned. Some in Ballykinnor in the north, but many went to Frangach in Wales and others went to places like Lewis Prison and Reading Jail and all of those. We'll talk about those, I think, a little bit later on. But of the 187 who are court-martialed, a number of them were sentenced to death. About 90 of them were given death sentences. As it turned out, 14 of them were executed in Kilmainham Jail, having been tried in secrecy without representation in a series of court
这是他们的机会。这就是以复活节作为起义时间的全部关键所在。这是一场牺牲。而且“血祭”这个词一次又一次地与这个时期联系在一起。因此有 187 人上了军事法庭。其余的人被关在各处的围栏里，最终遭到拘禁。一些人在北部的巴利金诺，但许多人去了威尔士的弗朗加奇，其他人去了刘易斯监狱和雷丁监狱等地。我想我们稍后会讨论这些地方。但在受审的 187 人中，其中许多人被判处死刑。大约 90 人被判处死刑。事实证明，其中 14 人在基尔梅因监狱被处决，他们在几次军事法庭上被秘密审判，没有辩护律师。
marches. But there was no doubt about guilt, to be fair. And the executions began on the morning of the 3rd of May when Patrick Pearce, Thomas Clarke and Thomas McDonagh were shot by firing squad in the stonebreakers yard of Kilmainham jail. They continued until the 12th of May. So 14 executions in that jail were strung out over 10 days. The last one to die was Sean McDiarmida and James Connolly. And James Connolly is a story that was really potent because Connolly was extremely ill and extremely injured. He was so bad he basically had to be tied to a chair so that he could be shot. His wife and his daughter, his daughter tells this story in heartbreaking detail later in the 60s of going in to see her father the night before he was shot
但公平地说，罪行是毋庸置疑的。处决始于 5 月 3 日早晨，当时帕特里克·皮尔斯、托马斯·克拉克和托马斯·麦克多纳在基尔梅因监狱的石匠场被行刑队枪决。处决一直持续到 5 月 12 日。因此，在该监狱进行的 14 次处决持续了 10 天。最后一个死去的是肖恩·麦克蒂尔马和詹姆斯·康利。詹姆斯·康利是一个非常具有感染力的故事，因为康利病得非常重，也受了重伤。他病情如此严重，以至于基本上必须被绑在椅子上才能被枪决。他的妻子和女儿——他的女儿在 60 年代以令人心碎的细节讲述了在她父亲被枪决的前一天晚上去看望他的情景——她的母亲在哭泣，而他对母亲说：“哦，别哭，你会让我失去男子气概的。”这是事后开始流传的故事之一，也是故事中极具感染力的部分。所以还有两次重要的处决。托马斯·肯特在科克并未真正参与任何起义。对于 1916 年一个反叛郡来说，科克非常平静。科克几乎什么都没发生。但另一个轰动的大事件是罗杰·卡斯门特。
and her mother crying and him saying, oh, don't cry, you'll unman me. And it's one of these stories begin to come out afterwards, and they're potent ones in the story. So there were two more executions that matter. Thomas Kent down in Cork wasn't really involved in any rising. Cork was very quiet for a rebel county in 1916. Very little happened in Cork. But the other big one is Roger Casement.
是的。所以罗杰·卡斯门特在最近的剧集中有出场。是的，在刚果。在刚果，他揭露了比利时人在该地区的非凡虐待行为。还去了亚马逊的普图马约地区揭露了更多恶行，他是一位受封的爵士，出生于都柏林，但实际上与阿尔斯特工会主义联系紧密，他是一名新教徒，后来日益转变为民族主义者，甚至到了罗杰·卡斯门特在战争爆发后前往德国，并试图从德国人关押的被俘战俘中组建一支爱尔兰团的地步，他试图让德国人提供枪支。他没有成功组建一个团，但他让德国人……
Yeah. So Roger Casement is featured in recent episodes. Yeah, the Congo. Did in the Congo, where he exposed extraordinary abuses by the Belgians in that area. Also went to the Potomayo region in the Amazon exposed more there was a knight of the realm had been born in Dublin, but was really associated with Ulster unionism was a Protestant who increasingly converted to nationalism to the point where Roger Casement went to Germany after the outbreak of war and tried to raise an Irish regiment from captured prisoners of war held by the Germans, tries to get the Germans to give guns. He doesn't manage to raise a regiment, but he gets the Germans
给他们提供枪支，这些枪支是通过潜艇运回来的。但他在复活节起义那个周末抵达时被捕了。他被带到伦敦塔。他受审并被定罪。有一场上诉。但没有成功。这引发了一场巨大无比的轰动。所以，我们现在进入了八月。起义发生在四月。时间到了八月。他在八月初的一个早晨在本顿维尔监狱被一个来自罗奇代尔的理发师约翰·埃利斯绞死，当他执行死刑时，有人在路上欢呼，还有人在用爱尔兰语祈祷和哀悼。这是一个非凡的场景。我们应该谈谈实际上没有被处决的一个人……
to give them guns, which come back on a submarine. But he's arrested when he arrived on the weekend of the Easter Rising. He's brought to the Tower of London. He's tried, convicted. There's an appeal. It doesn't wash. And there's a huge, huge fuss about this. So this, we're on into August now. The rising took place in April. It's into August. And he was hung a morning early in August in Pentonville prison by a hairdresser from Rochdale called John Ellis, who when he did the execution, there were people out in the road cheering and there were others praying and lamenting in Irish. An extraordinary scene. And we should talk about one person actually who wasn't executed
因为他将在接下来的故事中扮演极其重要的角色。这个人叫埃蒙·德·瓦莱拉，任何爱尔兰听众无疑都会对他非常熟悉。但我们的一些英国和美国听众等等可能就没那么熟悉了。所以给我们讲讲关于德瓦莱拉的一些事。嗯，我从我人生中的第一个记忆开始，那就是去参加德瓦莱拉的葬礼。他在 1975 年遗体停灵供瞻仰。当时我在都柏林城堡，五岁大。所以他大概有 150 岁了。是的，我老得很优雅。
because he'll play a massive part in this story. And this is a man called Eamonn de Valera who any Irish listener will undoubtedly be familiar with. But some of our British and American listeners and whatnot may be not so much. So tell us a bit about de Valera. Well I start from the fact that it's probably my first memory in life was going to De Valera's funeral. He was left lying in state in 1975. I was five years of age in Dublin Castle. So he's about 150. Yeah, I'm aging quite gracefully.
他在那里。不过，躺在那个灵柩里的人是……我们排了几个小时的队才进去，而且符合我性格的典型表现，我一路都在哭闹抱怨，但当我看到它时，我还想回去再看一眼。不过，那棺材大概很长，因为他被称为“高个子”。是的，他是“高个子”，也是历史上总是与他结为双人组并被历史简化为对他们两人的漫画式描绘的人。迈克尔·柯林斯是“大个子”。所以德瓦莱拉……
He was there. The man who was in that box, though, was... We queued up for hours to get in and typically of my character I winched and cried the whole way through, but when I'd seen it I wanted to go back and have another look. But presumably a very long coffin because he's known as the long fella. Yeah, he's the long fella and is the man who he's always twinned with in history and reduced by history to caricature of both of them. Michael Collins is the big fella. So De Valera
是“高个子”，柯林斯是“大个子”。真是的，历史余音。所以德瓦莱拉，我的意思是他主导了 20 世纪的爱尔兰政治。并且他在某些方面也主导了这个故事。所以给我们讲讲他的性格。人们对他的看法是那种非常冷冰冰的、严厉的、神职人员般的性格。这公平吗？那是对的。而这种形象，当他在 50 年代末到 70 年代初担任爱尔兰总统时，他几乎双目失明。他是一个非常年老、步履蹒跚的人物。那是电视捕捉到的形象。所以这也是留在公众心目中的形象。但是德瓦莱拉，他出生于纽约，母亲是一名爱尔兰女性，父亲显然是一名西班牙人。
is the long fella and Collins is the big fella. Quite, rest is history. So De Valera, I mean, he dominates Irish politics in the 20th century. And he also dominates the story in some ways. So tell us a bit about his character. The perception of him is this very chilly, sort of austere, clerical character. Is that fair? And that's right. And this image of him, by the time he was president of Ireland from the late 50s to the early 70s, he was almost blind. He was very old, doddery figure. And that's the one that television captured. So it's the one that has stuck in the public mind. But the De Valera, who was born in New York to an Irish woman and apparently a Spanish
所以他才有了这个名字。所以，必须指出的是，戴维·麦卡洛关于埃蒙·德·瓦莱拉的传记真的很好，它对他的确切身世画上了问号。顺便说一句，这是德瓦莱拉的对手们一生都在攻击他的事情。他很小的时候就被带回了家，被安置在利imerick郡布鲁里的老家族宅邸里，不过他的母亲留在了纽约。德瓦莱拉由惠勒家族的成员抚养长大。他是一个非常聪明的孩子，获得了市里精英黑岩学院的奖学金，擅长数学。
father. So hence his name. So, but it must be said David McCullough's biography on this, on Eamon de Valera is really good and it throws question marks over quite exactly what the parentage is. Something by the way, which De Valera's opponents threw at him all his life. He was brought home when he was very young, treated to the old family home in Brewery in County Limerick, though his mother remained in New York. And Devalero was raised by Weiler family members. He was a really bright kid, got a scholarship to the elite Black Rock College in the city here, was skilled at mathematics,
发现了爱尔兰语，并且这个被以一种非常特定方式呈现的男人的漫画形象。从那个时期的经历中你看不到这一点。他非常乐意出去喝酒。他当然也去追求过女孩子，而且在某一阶段，他曾在罗克韦尔学院担任数学老师，并且热爱橄榄球。绝对热爱橄榄球，并获得了为芒斯特橄榄球队试训的机会。他作为殿卫（全卫）参加了试训，而那个……
discovered the Irish language and the caricature of this man who was presented in a very particular way. You can't see it from those periods. He was more than happy to go out drinking. He certainly went courting and down in, he went working in Rockwell College as a maths teacher at one stage and loved rugby. Absolutely loved rugby and got a trial for the Munster rugby team. He was trialled as fullback and the guy
在他之前被选中的那个人那一年为爱尔兰队效力了。所以德瓦莱拉本可以轻易成为一名国际橄榄球运动员。但他对数学非常热衷，并且适时地提出了各种复杂的数学方案，不是吗？试图化圆为方等等。他有一个非常有趣的头脑，是的，但也同样被漫画化了，因为他被描绘成一个严厉的人，但他在 1916 年带着枪走上街头，加入了一场起义。
who was picked ahead of him played for Ireland that year. So De Valera could easily have been an international rugby player. But very keen on maths and he comes up with all kinds of complicated mathematical schemes in due course, doesn't he? To try and square circles and so on. He had a very interesting mind and yes, but is also again kind of caricatured in that because he's portrayed as being someone who was austere, but he went out with a gun in 1916 and joined a rebellion.
那一年入选在他前面的人曾代表爱尔兰队出场。所以德·瓦莱拉本来完全有可能成为一名国际橄榄球运动员。但他对数学非常热衷，日后他想出了各种复杂的数学方案，对吧？比如试图化圆为方等等。他的思维非常有趣，是的，但人们对他也有一种刻板印象，因为他被塑造成一个生活简朴、严于律己的人，然而他在1916年却带着枪走上街头，参加了一场起义。
But he does kind of lean into the stereotype, doesn't he, himself? So there's this famous phrase in that every instinct of mine would indicate that I was meant to be a died in the wall Tory or even a bishop rather than the leader of a revolution. Yes, he's again, we keep using the word complex, but he is a complex individual throughout all of this. And here's the thing, he's not executed. he could have been executed, but he is not executed because he's an American citizen. Yeah, again, that's what's said, that it's because he was an American citizen, but it is also the case. The British Prime Minister, Haskell, had been telling the military authorities in Ireland, stop killing these people, because already there are Catholic bishops calling
但他也确实有点倾向于那种刻板印象，不是吗？他自己也是。所以在那个时期有一句名言：我所有的直觉都告诉我，我注定是一个死硬的托利党人，甚至是个主教，而不是一场革命的领袖。是的，他又一次——我们一直在用“复杂”这个词——但他在这整件事中确实是一个复杂的人物。而且关键是，他没有被处决。他本可以被处决，但他没有被处决，因为他是美国公民。是的，又来了，人们就是这么说的，说是因为他是美国公民，但事实也确实如此。当时的英国首相阿斯奎斯一直在对驻爱尔兰的军方当局说：别再杀这些人了，因为已经有天主教主教在大声疾呼
for the executions to stop, there are newspapers calling for it. So this takes us to the crucial next step, which is that there's clearly a change in atmosphere in the, I don't know, six months, 12 months after the Easter Rising. There is a sense of a change in the tone, in a gathering momentum towards nationalism. And just talk us through some of that. So this is to do with obviously the reaction to the executions since the rising but there are also books being published, it's a sporting story. How does the mood change in this period? The first way the mood changes is by the people who are sent to camps being brought home. So they're coming home, they're released
要求停止处决，也有报纸在呼吁。所以这就把我们带到了至关重要的下一步，也就是在复活节起义后的六个月或十二个月里，气氛显然发生了变化。人们能感觉到基调变了，一种走向民族主义的势头正在积聚。请给我们讲讲这方面的情况。这显然与对起义后处决行动的反应有关，但当时也有书籍出版，这是一场体育盛事。在这个时期，人们的心情是如何变化的？心情发生变化的第一种方式是被流放到集中营的人被送回了家。他们正回到家，被释放
aereally from Fronga. The military intelligence, the police intelligence was useless. They lifted a whole load of people who had nothing to do with the rising, so they let them out sometimes after three, four weeks. But across that autumn and winter of 1916, as far as Christmas morning 1916, a ship carrying both soldiers from the Western Front and released Republican prisoners from English jails, sails into Dublin port, the dawn is breaking and there's four in particular who pushed their way up from Stearidge to First Class. There's Col O'Shaughnan and Terence
从弗龙戈赫（Fronga）陆陆续续回来。当时的军事情报和警察情报简直毫无用处。他们抓了一大批和起义毫无关系的人，所以在三四周后有时就把他们放了。但在1916年的那个秋冬，直到1916年的圣诞节早晨，一艘载着来自西线战场的士兵和从英国监狱释放的共和党囚犯的船驶入了都柏林港，黎明正在破晓，其中有四个人特别引人注目，他们从斯蒂尔奇（Stearidge）挤到了头等舱。他们是科尔·奥肖内森（Col O'Shaughnan）和特伦斯
McSweeney, later Lord Mayor of Cork. Sean Tio Kelly, later President of Ireland, and Ernest Blyde, who is later in the First Cabinet and himself a Protestant. But up on the top as the the ship pulls in, is Tomás MacCartan, later also Lord Mayor of Cork, and he's playing the fiddle. And on the key to greet them as they come out of the murk are loads of people with tricolours because they're cheering another group of people who were home. Around that there's a film, Ireland the Nation, which kind of depicts the famine in 1798, which celebrates Irishness, that's been shown in cinemas around America.
麦克西尼（McSweeney，后来的科克市长）、肖恩·蒂奥·凯利（Sean Tio Kelly，后来的爱尔兰总统），以及欧内斯特·布莱德（Ernest Blyde，他后来进入了第一届内阁，本人也是个新教徒）。但当船靠岸时，站在最上面的是托马斯·麦卡坦（Tomás MacCartan，后来也担任过科克市长），他正在拉小提琴。在他们从昏暗中走出来时，码头上迎接他们的是成群结队手持三色旗的人，因为他们在欢呼另一群回家的人。在那前后，有一部名为《爱尔兰，这个国家》（Ireland the Nation）的电影上映了，它描绘了1798年的饥荒，歌颂了爱尔兰精神，这部电影当时在美国各地的电影院上映。
There are books like the Sinn Fein Rebellion Handbook hugely popular on the all-Ireland hurling final of 1916 not played until 1917. The Tipperary hurlers who feature hugely in the story later on come up and they go to the GPO and they say prayers amidst the rubble so that's becoming an iconic site. There are collections for the funds of prisoners, which Michael Collins gets involved in, and we'll be talking about Collins later on. And then a year after the Rising, on the day that James Connolly, the anniversary of James Connolly's execution, a huge sign is put up onto the Liberty Hall, that home of trade
还有一些书，比如《新芬党叛乱手册》（Sinn Fein Rebellion Handbook），极其受欢迎；1916年的全爱尔兰板球（hurling）决赛直到1917年才举行。在故事后期发挥重要作用的蒂珀雷里（Tipperary）板球运动员们也赶了过来，他们来到邮政总局（GPO），在废墟中默默祈祷，这里正逐渐成为一个标志性的地点。人们开始为囚犯基金进行募捐，迈克尔·科林斯也参与其中，我们稍后会谈到科林斯。在起义一年后的那一天，也就是詹姆斯·康诺利（James Connolly）被处决的周年纪念日，利伯蒂厅（Liberty Hall）——那个爱尔兰工会主义的发源地——挂上了一个巨大的标语。
unionism in Ireland. The place which had the sign before the rising which said, we serve neither King nor Kaiser, now has a sign on it which says James Connolly murdered 12th of May 1916. It was only up for a very short period, possibly only an hour, but it was photographed as part of propaganda to be sold alongside the books and rosettes and flags that were now ubiquitous amongst people who had been swayed. And is there a sense that the nationalist movement is breaking new ground with propaganda? That it's out thinking the royalist British assumptions about propaganda? Well, you must remember that at this point, British interest in Ireland was so
起义前，那里挂着的标语写着“我们既不效忠国王，也不效忠凯撒”；而现在，标语上写着：“詹姆斯·康诺利于1916年5月12日被谋杀”。这块标语只挂了很短的时间，可能只有一个小时，但它被拍了下来，作为宣传品出售，与那些现在在被感化的民众中无处不在的书籍、玫瑰花结和旗帜放在一起。人们会不会觉得民族主义运动正在用宣传开拓新的领域？它是不是在思想上超越了保皇派英国人对宣传的假设？嗯，你必须记住，当时英国对爱尔兰的关注是如此之少
minimal as to be exceptionally difficult to quantify because the war was raging in Europe. Britain was in an existential fight. The United Kingdom was really in turmoil. The mines were focused elsewhere. It wasn't focused on Ireland. Ireland never truly mattered in British politics after 1914. I'm not saying it didn't matter at all, but it was not central to the story in the way it had been in 1914 despite the rebellion. You can see that in newspapers, cabinet meetings and all these kinds of things. It's there, but it's never the biggest thing. Before we go to the break, let's
以至于少到极难量化，因为欧洲的战争正在激烈进行。英国正处于一场生死存亡的战斗中。英国确实陷入了混乱。他们的主要精力集中在其他地方，没有集中在爱尔兰。1914年后，爱尔兰在英国政治中从未真正重要过。我并不是说它一点都不重要，但它不像1914年那样处于故事的核心，尽管发生了叛乱。从报纸、内阁会议和所有这些事情中都可以看出这一点。它虽然存在，但从来都不是最重要的事情。在我们休息一下之前，让我们
talk about two groups in particular. So one is, you've already mentioned the fact that not everybody is a nationalist. So about 30% of the population of Ireland would regard themselves as unionists, and these are predominantly but not exclusively Protestants. So while all this is going on, are they just watching in horror and indifference? What do they think? Well, it's even more complex than that because their leaders, including Edward Carson, Edward Carson is now in the British cabinet. And so the connections between the formation of coalition government in England allowed
来谈谈两个特定的群体。其中一个群体是——你刚才已经提到过并非每个人都是民族主义者。大约30%的爱尔兰人口认为自己是联合派，他们绝大多数（但不仅限于）是新教徒。所以，当这一切都在发生时，他们只是在惊恐和冷漠地旁观吗？他们是怎么想的？嗯，情况甚至比这还要复杂，因为他们的领袖，包括爱德华·卡森（Edward Carson），现在已经进入了英国内阁。因此，英格兰联合政府的组建使得
for Ulster unionism to reach right into the cabinet table and the shift in power. Whereas previously the Liberals had depended on Irish nationalist votes, that is gone now. It's now unionists who sit in cabinet and in power. They still stand rejecting our home rule. Nothing has changed there. Indeed, the myth of Ulster continues to grow. Built incredibly in another event in 1916, the Battle of the Somme, at which the 36th Ulster Division suffered horrendous losses on the first day.
阿尔斯特联合主义者能够直接进入内阁权力核心，从而实现了权力转移。而在此之前，自由党一直依赖爱尔兰民族主义者的选票，这种局面已经不复存在了。现在坐在内阁和权力宝座上的是联合派。他们依然坚决拒绝自治。这一点没有任何改变。事实上，阿尔斯特的神话仍在继续膨胀。它在1916年的另一个事件——索姆河战役中得到了极大的构筑，第36阿尔斯特师在那场战役的第一天遭遇了惨重的伤亡。
And if I went to see those trenches that they were fought in, I went to see the monument in Tiepfil, which was erected to the Ulster Unionists who were there. It's an incredibly well-kept, preserved, iconic part of that story. And it's fed in to the myth of Ulster and supported by Kipling and Elgar and all the voices of empire. And St Paul, that's another Irish blood sacrifice offered up in 1916. Yes, and again, it sits right at the heart of the mythology of unionism just as 1916.
如果我去参观他们战斗过的战壕，去参观蒂普瓦尔（Tiepfil）为阵亡的阿尔斯特联合派树立的纪念碑，就会发现那是这个故事中一个极其完好保存、极具标志性的部分。它滋养了阿尔斯特的神话，并得到了吉卜林、埃尔加以及所有帝国声音的支持。而圣保罗……那是1916年献上的又一份爱尔兰血祭。是的，而且它再次成为了联合主义神话的核心，就像1916年一样。
I mean, it's so extraordinary, isn't it, that the two communities are both creating these mythic blood sacrifices in their imaginings. And it's in the language that's been used in all of this. You see, James Dillon stood in the House of Commons and talked about the blood that was going to flow in Ireland. He was the really potent member of the Irish parliamentary party, a moderate,
我的意思是，两个社群在各自的想象中都在创造这些神话般的血祭，这不是很不可思议吗？这一切都体现在他们所使用的语言中。你看，詹姆斯·狄龙（James Dillon）曾在下议院发言，谈到将要在爱尔兰流淌的鲜血。他是爱尔兰议会党内真正有影响力的成员，一个温和派，
stood in the House of Commons and said, you're creating a revolution here. Yeah. Because you're killing these men. There is blood flowing out from under the cell doors. The British ambassador in America, Wright Holman says there are blood in the eyes of Irish Americans. So things have been fundamentally transformed by the 1916 rising, both north and south. And so the second group just before we go to the break are the British. What are the British thinking is going to be the medium to long term outcome?
曾站在下议院说：你们在这里制造一场革命。是的。因为你们在杀害这些人。鲜血正从牢门底下流出来。英国驻美国大使赖特·霍尔曼（Wright Holman）说，爱尔兰裔美国人眼里充满了血丝。因此，1916年的起义彻底改变了一切，无论是南方还是北方。在我们休息之前要谈的第二个群体是英国人。英国人认为的中长期结果会是什么？
What is their plan? So, Askwith is Prime Minister, but he is toppled and replaced by David Lloyd George, who is basically in coalition with the Conservatives and increasingly reliant upon the Conservatives, who we know are great friends of the Ulster Unionists. What does Lloyd George think is going to happen to Ireland? They're still planning home rule, aren't they? So in the middle of 1916, in the summer of 1916, before he became Prime Minister, David Lloyd George was Minister of Munitions and he attempted to introduce home rule. He was charged with asking about a fix in the crisis. Lloyd George went at it with, he celebrated as a cunning mind, but you could equally say he was a man so crooked he couldn't lie straight in bed.
他们的计划是什么？所以，阿斯奎斯（Asquith）是首相，但他被推翻了，取而代之的是大卫·劳埃德·乔治（David Lloyd George）。劳埃德·乔治基本上与保守党结盟，并且越来越依赖我们所知道的阿尔斯特联合派的坚定朋友——保守党。劳埃德·乔治认为爱尔兰会发生什么？他们仍在计划自治，不是吗？所以在1916年中期，即1916年夏天，在他成为首相之前，大卫·劳埃德·乔治担任军需大臣，他试图推行自治。他被指派去解决这场危机。劳埃德·乔治以他那备受赞誉的狡猾头脑着手处理此事，但你同样可以说，他是一个狡猾到连在床上都躺不直的人。
Lloyd George told different things to both sides in promising Home Rule. He told Carson that Home Rule, he's the head of the Unionists, that well, listen, we'll give a separate parliament for the six counties and you can permanently stay out of Home Rule, the rest of Ireland can get their 26 counties. But he told John Redmond, the leader of the Irish Moderates, that, well, no, listen, we're going to keep the North out but only for a while. He kind of went between the two things but he couldn't square the language to get it through. So that fell apart. The Devil Eras mastery of maths. But by the time you get to 1917, there is no plan.
劳埃德·乔治在承诺自治时，对双方说了不同的话。他告诉联合派领袖卡森：“听着，我们将在六个郡设立一个独立的议会，你们可以永久排除在自治之外，爱尔兰其余地区可以得到他们的26个郡。”但他却对爱尔兰温和派领袖约翰·雷德蒙（John Redmond）说：“不，听着，我们要把北方排除在外，但只是暂时的。”他在这两种说法之间摇摆不定，却无法协调好措辞来让法案通过。所以计划破产了。埃斯特雷（指德瓦莱拉）对数学的精通……但到了1917年，已经没有任何计划了。
Right. There is no sense of what can be done here. There's the idea that we'll put in Home Rule and we might get a partition, a settlement, but how that's going to be delivered to Irish nationalists who might consider a temporary exclusion for Ulster, but not a permanent one. And Ulster unions were saying, well, we don't want Home Rule at all, but if we must do something, it's permanent. So Paul, you mentioned John Redmond, who is the leader of the moderate nationalists, the party that has been campaigning for Home Rule, supportive of Home Rule. But lurking in the
没错。根本没有迹象表明这里还能做些什么。当时有一种想法，就是我们推行自治，然后可能会达成某种划分或妥协，但要如何向那些或许能接受阿尔斯特暂时被排除在外、却绝不接受永久排除的爱尔兰民族主义者们交待这一点呢？而阿尔斯特联合派则表示：我们根本不想要自治，但如果非得做点什么，那必须是永久性的。保罗，你刚才提到了约翰·雷德蒙，他是温和派民族主义者的领袖，也就是那个一直为自治奔走、支持自治的政党领袖。但在这一切的
background all along, there is another party, another organisation that we haven't mentioned yet, but will be playing a huge part in the story. And that is a party called Sinn Fein in English, ourselves alone. And I think we should take a break now and when we come back, we will look at the role played by Sinn Fein in this story. No Frills delivers. Get groceries delivered to your door from No Frills with PC Express. Shop online and get $15 in PC optimum No Frills with PC Express. Shop online and get $15 in PC Optimum Points on your first five orders. Shop now at NoFrails.ca. Hello to our lovely Rezzes Entertainment listeners. This is me, Marina Hyde. And me, Richard Osmond. Hello, everybody.
背景深处，还潜藏着另一个政党、另一个我们尚未提及但将在故事中扮演极其重要角色的组织。那就是一个名为“新芬党”（Sinn Fein，在爱尔兰语中意为“我们自己”）的政党。我想我们现在应该休息一下，回来后，我们将探讨新芬党在这个故事中扮演的角色。No Frills为您提供便捷服务。使用PC Express从No Frills订购杂货并直接送货上门。网购并在前五笔订单中获得15加元的PC Optimum积分。立即访问NoFrills.ca选购。亲爱的《娱乐往事》（The Restis Entertainment）听众朋友们，你们好。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。还有我，理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。大家好。
Now our two-part deep dive into the chaotic production of Jaws, the first blockbuster has been a smash hit, bit like the film itself. And that has been a huge hit with our club members. Yeah, the response has been incredible. Thank you all so much. Deep dive is an unfortunate thing to say in relation to Jaws, but I know what you mean.
现在，我们分两部分深入探讨第一部大片《大白鲨》那混乱的制作过程的节目大获成功，就像这部电影本身一样火爆。这对我们的俱乐部成员来说是一个巨大的轰动。是的，大家的反应令人难以置信。非常感谢大家。“深入探讨”（Deep dive）这个词用在《大白鲨》上听起来有点不太吉利，但我明白你们的意思。
It's great to be able to do these deep dives into the entertainment stories that are off the beaten track. We'd have to do topical stuff. We can tell like amazing stories about amazing movies, amazing albums, amazing characters, amazing stories from the past of showbiz and entertainment. There's so many history really. Yeah, it's like the rest of history, but you know, you get to talk about Noel Edmonds. Okay, so here is the thing. Just like Universal, who were desperate to get their money back
能够对那些鲜为人知的娱乐故事进行深入探讨，感觉真的很棒。我们不得不做一些时事话题。我们可以讲述关于精彩电影、精彩专辑、精彩人物的精彩故事，以及来自演艺界和娱乐界过去的精彩故事。这里面其实有太多的历史。是的，这就像历史的其余部分，你知道的，你还可以谈论诺埃尔·埃德蒙兹（Noel Edmonds）。好吧，事情是这样的。就像环球影业迫切想要收回他们的投资一样
with a nationwide release of Jaws, We want all our listeners to experience what our club members have been raving about. Hold on a second. Are you saying what I think you're saying, which is for a limited time, you can access our Jaws series absolutely free just by visiting therestesentertainment.com. That is exactly what I'm saying. You have got to be kidding me. It is the perfect way to discover why our bonus content is so special and why club membership is absolutely worth it.
通过在全国上映《大白鲨》，我们希望所有的听众都能体验到我们的俱乐部成员一直赞不绝口的内容。等等。你是在说我想的那件事吗？也就是说，在限时内，你只需访问therestesentertainment.com，就可以完全免费收听我们的《大白鲨》系列节目？这正是我要说的。你一定是在开玩笑吧。这是了解为什么我们的独家内容如此特别、为什么俱乐部会员资格绝对物超所值的绝佳方式。
We're going to need a bigger podcast. Join the Rest is Entertainment Club today by visiting therestisentertainment.com. We'll see you there. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History and the clock is ticking on British rule in Ireland. And Paul, we mentioned Féin just before the break. So tell us about Sinn Féin. So Sinn Féin is described in the commission of inquiry to the rebellion as being the driving force behind the rebellion of
我们需要一个更大的播客。今天就访问therestesentertainment.com加入“娱乐往事”俱乐部吧。我们到时见。欢迎回到《历史往事》（The Rest is History），英国在爱尔兰统治的倒计时正在滴答作响。保罗，我们在休息前提到了新芬党。那么给我们讲讲新芬党吧。新芬党在关于叛乱的调查委员会报告中被描述为1916年
1960 and it had nothing to do with it in the sense of nothing practical, but it had an impact on the ideas that were swirling around Irish society from the early 1900s onwards. And those ideas coalesced particularly around an individual called Arthur Griffith, who is one of the most important people in this whole story. So Griffith was a man who went to national school, but never went to secondary school really, and did his learning beside us here in the National Library of Ireland. He, like so many others, so many other revolutionaries in so many other countries, had work as a printer.
叛乱背后的驱动力，虽然它与叛乱在实际行动上没有任何关系，但它对20世纪初以来在爱尔兰社会中流传的思想产生过影响。这些思想特别围绕着一个名叫亚瑟·格里菲斯（Arthur Griffith）的人凝聚在一起，他是整个故事中最重要的人物之一。格里菲斯上过国民学校，但实际上从未上过中学，他的知识是在我们身边的爱尔兰国家图书馆里自学得来的。和许多其他人一样——许多在许多其他国家投身革命的人一样——他曾是一名印刷工。
So he went into that world of books and of newspapers and became a journalist. He went to live in South Africa for a while and then when he came back, he founded new newspapers, which he kind of shared this idea of Irish nationality, Irish nationalism, and this idea that little countries around the world, he wrote a lot about other countries. And in particular, Hungary, because he has this idea that basically the United Kingdom can become an Austro-Hungarian dual monarchy where King George or whoever is the King in Ireland but Ireland has its own separate parliament. And this is just to make sure things are particularly complicated. It makes the fact that Sinn Féin is not a Republican party until 1917 when it changes its particular policies until the autumn of 1917. It did wish for independence though and huge power with the figurehead
因此，他进入了书籍和报纸的世界，成为了一名记者。他在南非住了一段时间，回来后创办了新的报纸，在报纸上分享他对爱尔兰国籍、爱尔兰民族主义的看法，以及世界各地小国（他写了很多关于其他国家的文章）的想法。特别是匈牙利，因为他有一种设想，即基本上英国可以变成一个奥匈帝国式的二元君主国，乔治国王或任何人在爱尔兰担任国王，但爱尔兰拥有自己独立的议会。为了让事情变得特别复杂。这使得新芬党在1917年秋天改变其特定政策之前，直到1917年都不是一个共和党派。不过，它确实渴望独立，并且拥有巨大的权力，而君主则是其象征性的门面。
of the monarch. But the notion that Sinn Féin began as a monarchist party is one of my favourite Irish history facts. It is a slight reduction, but I take the point, though. In Ireland, Griffith's notion of nationality was that he was a geographic determinist, as Michael Affan has said, so that irrespective of background or religion, if you were born in the Ireland, you're Irish. That's how he saw it. And that's a tradition of Irish identity that again goes back to the Napoleonic period, the Revolutionary period. The thing with Griffith is that Griffith was actually a member of the
然而，新芬党最初作为一个君主制政党建立的这一概念，是我最喜欢的爱尔兰历史趣闻之一。这虽然有点简化，但我懂你的意思。在爱尔兰，格里菲斯的民族主义观念是，他是一个地理决定论者，正如迈克尔·阿凡（Michael Affan）所说的那样，无论背景或宗教信仰如何，只要你出生在爱尔兰，你就是爱尔兰人。他是这样看待这一点的。这也是爱尔兰身份认同的一种传统，可以追溯到拿破仑时期和革命时期。关于格里菲斯，有一点是事实：他实际上曾是
Irish Republican Brotherhood, though he kind of drifted away from that, not because he was against the use of arms, but because he didn't think it was possible for the Irish Republicans to go in armed rebellion and win. And he was only interested in winning. He was a pragmatic man. He pushed ideas around industrialization and forestation and the production of Irish goods against those things. So he wanted to build up a movement that was based on this. He's not a Tariffs fan, is he? He was, funnily enough, a Tariffs fan, very much of the moment. He was involved in the gun running for the Irish volunteers.
爱尔兰共和兄弟会（IRB）的成员，尽管他后来渐渐疏远了该组织，倒不是因为他反对使用武力，而是因为他认为爱尔兰共和派发动武装起义并取得胜利是不可能的。他只对取得胜利感兴趣。他是一个实用主义者。他大力推动工业化、造林以及生产爱尔兰本土商品以抵制外货的思想。因此，他希望建立一个以此为基础的运动。他不是关税的粉丝，对吧？说来也巧，他其实是个关税的支持者，非常合乎当时的潮流。他曾参与为爱尔兰志愿军（Irish Volunteers）走私武器。
So that shows you again, even though he didn't fight in the rising, he was not against revolutionary nationalism. His newspaper was suppressed during World War I. So he did something that was, I think, a piece of genius. He set up a new newspaper called Scissors and Paste. And there are copies of Scissors and Paste in the National Library and out in UCD. But what they are is, what he did was he took cuttings from other newspapers that had got by the censor and put them into a newspaper called Scissors and Paste and made his journalism out of stories that had already been published.
这再次向你表明，尽管他没有参加起义，但他并不反对革命民族主义。他的报纸在第一次世界大战期间被查封了。于是他做了一件我认为堪称天才的事。他创办了一份名为《剪报》（Scissors and Paste）的新报纸。在国家图书馆和大学学院（UCD）里都存有《剪报》的复印件。它的做法是，他把其他那些通过了审查的报纸上的剪报收集起来，汇编成一份名为《剪报》的报纸，用那些已经发表过的新闻来继续他的新闻事业。
To get around that didn't really work for too long and that too was suppressed. But the ideas that he had propagated over the first 16, 17 years of the 20th century were wrapped around ideas of Irish independence to the extent that the name Sinn Féin was applied to a rebellion of which they were not involved as a constituent organization. So in a sense the British and the authorities they haven't exactly invented the idea of Sinn Fein but they've changed Sinn Fein because they've turned it into something that it wasn't which is this sort of incredibly potent underground revolutionary organization. You see British politicians and
这种绕过审查的做法并没有维持太久，那份报纸最终也被查封了。但是，他在20世纪前16、17年里传播的思想，已经与爱尔兰独立的理念紧密交织在一起，以至于“新芬党”这个名字被安在了一场他们甚至没有作为组成组织参与的叛乱头上。因此从某种意义上说，英国人和当局并没有真正发明新芬党这个概念，但他们改变了新芬党，把它变成了一个原本并不存在的、极其强大的地下革命组织。你可以看到英国政客和
newspapers talking about the dangers of Sinn Fein and their Sinn Fein murder gang and whatnot all the time. So they've kind of created this chimera, I guess. And you see this as the people who were in the internment camps. They came up with plans in those camps. It was quite a remarkable thing to put people together who didn't know each other particularly well. Because the prison camps are described as a university. Exactly, the University of the Revolution. And they come home. And through 1917, as Sinn Féin begin to organise again,
报纸整天都在谈论新芬党的危险以及他们的新芬党谋杀团之类的东西。所以我想，他们某种程度上创造了这个幻影。你可以从那些被关押在拘留营的人身上看到这一点。他们在集中营里制定了计划。把那些原本并不太熟悉的人关在一起，是一件相当了不起的事。因为那些监狱被称为大学。没错，革命大学。他们回到了家。在1917年，随着新芬党开始重新组织，
as people come home, they begin to do things that are not just about independence. So they do practical things. They don't just make speeches and spout. They do things like they say, OK, we're going to boycott people who support this government. We're gonna boycott the Crown Forces. We're gonna boycott the police, number one. Number two, we're gonna go involved in land agitation.
随着人们回到家乡，他们开始做一些不仅仅关乎独立的事情。他们做一些非常实际的事。他们不仅仅是发表长篇大论和夸夸其谈。他们采取行动，比如他们说：“好吧，我们要抵制支持这个政府的人。我们要抵制皇室军队。我们要抵制警察，这是第一点。第二点，我们要参与土地激进运动。
So we're going to argue that the remaining land that is held by landowners that hasn't been distributed amongst tenant farmers must now be given out. Number three, they do into food agitation. Food agitation is important because of, of course, it's wartime and there's price issues and there's scarcity issues and someone like Dermot Flynn for example, common deo, Sinn Féin director of food, he comes and he gets 34 pigs that are about to be exported from Dublin Port, he takes them away, they're slaughtered and they're dispersed amongst the population. So that's an example I think think, of popular engagement.
所以我们要主张，土地所有者手中尚未分配给佃农的剩余土地现在必须分发出去。”第三点，他们开展食品抗议运动。食品抗议运动之所以重要，是因为当时正处于战事期间，存在价格问题和物资短缺问题，例如像德莫特·弗林（Dermot Flynn）这样的人，他是新芬党的一名食品主管（common deo），他赶来拦截了34头正准备从都柏林港出口的猪，把它们带走，宰杀后分发给民众。我认为，这就是民众参与的一个例子。
And you recognize this from revolutionary organizations around the world. This is not, these are things that revolutionary organizations do. It's a wider story made real here. But there is a strong sense that Sinn Féin are kind of leading the way in this, that Irish nationalists are kind of inventing a new kind of revolutionary agitation. And this really is said about the guerrilla war which comes, which we'll talk about I think in the next episode and the one afterwards. But for the moment, it's about Sinn Féin now beginning to compete in parliamentary politics. It puts up candidates. And they are obviously opposed to being a part of the Westminster parliament, but they are prepared to play the Westminster game to that degree that they are happy to stand
你从世界各地的革命组织中也能认出这一点。这并非孤例，这就是革命组织会做的事情。这里展现的是一个更加宏大的现实故事。但人们有一种强烈的感觉，即新芬党在这个过程中起到了引领作用，爱尔兰民族主义者正在开创一种新型的革命抗议活动。关于即将到来的游击战，人们确实也是这么说的，我们将在下一集和再下一集中讨论它。但就目前而言，重点是新芬党现在开始参与议会政治。它推出了候选人。他们显然反对成为威斯敏斯特议会的一部分，但他们准备在一定程度上玩转威斯敏斯特的游戏，比如他们乐意在补缺选举中推出候选人。
candidates in by-elections, for instance. They will stand candidates in by-elections, but they will not take their seats in the House of Commons. So it begins in February 1917 when Count Plunkett, the father of an executed 1916 leader, wins a by-election in Roscommon. And it has to be said there's a surprising number of counts and countesses involved in this story. Yeah, papal counts in this case.
他们会在补缺选举中推出候选人，但他们不会去下议院就职。这一切始于1917年2月，1916年被处决的一位领袖的父亲普伦凯特伯爵（Count Plunkett）在罗斯康common赢下了一场补缺选举。必须指出的是，这个故事中涉及相当数量的伯爵和伯爵夫人。是的，在这个案例中是教皇册封的伯爵。
And then the South Longford by-election, that's in May, that's another Sinn Fein triumph and it's a key moment because it brings us to the other big character of this story who's very involved in that campaign, who is Michael Collins. So he's not standing in that election, but he's behind the scenes. He's putting a lot of the strings, isn't he? And tell us a little bit about Collins, because he's such a massive character. So just as De Valera is reduced in history to this, as you say, the long fella. So Michael Collins is seen as this gun blazing rebel who just appears young and handsome, died at 33.
然后是南朗福德（South Longford）的补缺选举，那是在5月份，这是新芬党的又一次胜利，也是一个关键时刻，因为它把我们引向了这个故事的另一个核心人物，他积极参与了那场竞选，那就是迈克尔·科林斯。所以他没有参加那次竞选，但他是在幕后操盘。他在幕后牵线搭桥，不是吗？给我们讲讲科林斯吧，因为他是一个如此宏大的人物。正如德瓦莱拉在历史中被缩减为这样一个——正如你所说的高个子。迈克尔·科林斯则被视为这样一个冲锋陷阵的叛逆者，他年轻英俊突然出现，33岁就牺牲了。
Later, you'll come across that story in the Civil War. He was a man who was fated in society. He was really handsome, individual. He's called the big fella, isn't it? Because it's expressive of his charisma rather than his size. He's not particularly large. It's personality and charisma and that this sense of... Now, he divided opinion because there were people who found him
后来，你会在内战的故事中遇到他。他曾是社会上备受追捧的人物。他是一个非常英俊的个人。人们叫他“大个子”（the big fella），不是吗？因为这表达的是他的个人魅力，而不是他的身材。他其实长得不算特别高大。这是他的个性和魅力，以及那种……不过，他引发了不同的评价，因为有些人觉得他
brusque and overbearing as well as people who swore absolute allegiance to him. But Collins is much more than a gunman. In fact, Collins was a military organ organizer and had a brilliant brain for detail and organization, which he kind of flourished in London because he emigrated to London as a teenager. He's from Cork originally, can't you say? Yes, he's from Cork. He's from Cork and he went to London, worked in the post office and then... He loves post offices, doesn't he?
生硬、专横，也有人对她绝对效忠。但科林斯远不止是一个持枪暴徒。事实上，科林斯是一个军事组织者，拥有极其敏锐的细节和组织头脑，这在伦敦得到了施展，因为他十几岁时就移民去了伦敦。他原本来自科克，对吧？是的，他来自科克。他来自科克，去了伦敦，在邮政局工作，然后……他很喜欢邮政局，对吧？
He does. He then goes to the GPO in Dublin. He ends up in a different type of post office. He does wrestling and hurling on Clapham Common, apparently. He was secretary to a GAA club, a hurling club over there. He played for London, he played in the competitions over there, but it was in London that he joined the Irish Republican Brotherhood. He got into this emigrate world of people who were unreconciled to the Crown and he was slowly radicalized,
他确实很喜欢。后来他去了都柏林的邮政总局。他最终进入了另一种类型的邮政局。据说他在克拉珀姆公车（Clapham Common）摔跤和打板球。他是当地盖尔运动协会（GAA）一个板球俱乐部的秘书。他为伦敦队效力，并在那里的比赛中上场，正是在伦敦，他加入了爱尔兰共和兄弟会。他进入了那个不承认王室统治的移民世界，并慢慢被激进化了，
or rather quickly radicalized in fairness, and he came back from London to fight in the Rising in 1916 just before it. He was interned initially, but he was a nobody in the Rising. He'd been in the GPO, but he wasn't a well-known figure. But there's a leadership gap in the end of 1916 and 1917. De Valera and other ones of the significant leaders of the 1916 Rising who hadn't been killed are in jail. And Collins emerges as this figure who gets a job setting up Republican prisoners' funds around the place and he becomes a permanent organizer who helps build Sinn Fein through
或者说，平心而论，是相当迅速地被激进化了。他在1916年起义爆发前不久从伦敦返回，参加了起义。他最初被拘留了，但在起义中他只是个无名小卒。他曾在邮政总局，但并不是一个知名人物。然而，在1916年底和1917年，出现了一个领导层真空。德瓦莱拉和其他几位在起义中幸存且未被处决的重要领导人都被关在监狱里。科林斯作为这样一个人物脱颖而出：他接下了在各地建立共和党囚犯基金的工作，并成为了一名常设组织者，协助建立新芬党
1917 to run in the by-elections and it is his push of Joe McGuinness. Joe McGuinness is one of seven children who'd spent time in America, who'd set up a Gaelic League Irish language branch around Longford. He'd worked in the Draper shops in Camden Street, not too far from us here. He'd fought in the Easter Rising in the Four Courts, where I think you're going to go later in this series. That's where he was based under Ned Daly there. And he was sent to Lewis Prison. And it was from Lewis Prison that he was elected as the MP for South Longford in May 1917. And he won by apparently 37 votes.
在1917年参加补缺选举，正是他极力推举乔·麦吉尼斯（Joe McGuinness）。乔·麦吉尼斯是七个孩子中的一个，曾在美国待过，在朗福德建立了一个盖尔语联盟爱尔兰语分支。他曾在卡姆登街（Camden Street）的一家布店工作，离我们现在这里不远。他曾在复活节起义中在四法院（Four Courts）战斗过，我想你在这个系列的后面会去那里参观。他当时就在那里，隶属于内德·戴利（Ned Daly）麾下。他被送往刘易斯监狱（Lewis Prison）。正是在刘易斯监狱里，他于1917年5月当选为南朗福德的下议院议员。他以区区37票的优势获胜。
And it was Collins who pushed that he run in the first place against the wishes of other people who thought it was ridiculous and that he could not win. It was Collins who drove the campaign, who brought men in cars down to Longford to campaign for him. And he stayed all the time in the Greville Arms Hotel, a great arms hotel in the middle of Granard and it was there where he met Kitty Kiernan who he ended up engaged to. Julia Roberts. Julia Roberts. So, so.
正是科林斯力排众议，不顾其他人认为这荒谬且不可能取胜的想法，坚持推举他参选。是科林斯推动了整个竞选活动，用汽车把男人们载到朗福德为他助选。他一直住在格雷维尔阿尔姆斯酒店（Greville Arms Hotel），那是格拉纳德（Granard）市中心的一家伟大的阿尔姆斯酒店，正是在那里，他遇到了基蒂·基尔南（Kitty Kiernan），两人后来订婚了。朱莉娅·罗伯茨。朱莉娅·罗伯茨。
You have to say it. Yeah, I mean, everyone was thinking. So, you talked about a leadership gap and Collins is sort of emerging, he's rising up the ladder. But of course, the person who does become the president of Sinn Fein is the person who ends up being his rival, which is Eamonn de Valera. How is it that de Valera rather than Griffiths becomes the president of Sinn Fein at the end of 1917?
你不得不这么说。是的，我的意思是，每个人都在这么想。所以，你谈到了领导层真空，科林斯正在崭露头角，在阶梯上不断攀升。但当然，最终成为新芬党主席的人，也就是最终成为他劲敌的人，是埃蒙·德瓦莱拉。为什么在1917年底成为新芬党主席的是德瓦莱拉而不是格里菲斯？
So there's distrust of Griffith. Despite his years in the movement, he had left the IRB and he was still a monarchist in early 1917 in the sense he was willing to accept that. So you have a man who didn't fight in 1916 and still gave allegiance to monarchy. And then you have Eamon de Valera, the most powerful surviving leader of that rebellion, who comes back from jail in the summer of 1917. De Valera and Griffith meet and they have a conversation and it's agreed that De Valera will be president and Griffith will be his vice president. And Griffith serves faithfully the cause after that point. And Paul said all this parliamentarian shenanigans, but what about the military aspect to this,
因为人们对格里菲斯不信任。尽管他在运动中浸润多年，但他已经离开了爱尔兰共和兄弟会，并且在1917年初仍然是一个君主主义者，在某种程度上他愿意接受这一点。所以你有一个没有参加过1916年起义、且依然效忠君主制的人。然后你有了埃蒙·德瓦莱拉，那是那场叛乱中幸存下来的最有权势的领袖，他在1917年夏天从监狱里回来了。德瓦莱拉和格里菲斯会面并进行了交谈，双方同意由德瓦莱拉担任主席，格里菲斯担任副主席。此后，格里菲斯一直忠诚地为这个事业服务。保罗刚才提到了所有的议会闹剧，但军事方面呢？
or I should probably say the paramilitary aspect to this? So in October 1917, when there was an Ardèche, or kind of an annual conference of Sinn Féin, at which Éamon de Valera was elected as president. And it was agreed that the policy of Sinn Féin would be to establish, and I quote, an independent Irish Republic. And de Valera formulated a kind of a unanimously accepted compromise around the nature of what that Republic would be when it was said Sinn Féin aims at securing the international recognition of Ireland
或者我应该说准军事方面？所以在1917年10月，当新芬党召开阿尔德什大会（Ardèche，即年度代表大会）时，埃蒙·德瓦莱拉当选为主席。会议一致同意，新芬党的政策将是建立——引用原话——“一个独立的爱尔兰共和国”。德瓦莱拉就该共和国性质的本质制定了一种获得一致接受的妥协方案，当时他说，新芬党的目标是争取国际社会对爱尔兰的承认，
as an independent Irish republic. Having achieved that status, the Irish people may by referendum choose their own form of government. So that's what pulled everyone together. And that's the point at which the movement coalesced from that point onwards. And then there were still by-elections being won. But at precisely the same weekend there was a volunteer convention around the Ardèche of Sinn Féin. So that is to say the Irish volunteers, the military wing is beginning to maneuver again. Many of those who've
将其视为一个独立的爱尔兰共和国。在达成这一地位后，爱尔兰人民可以通过全民公投选择自己的政府形式。这就是将所有人团结在一起的纽带。也就是从那时起，整个运动开始凝聚成形。随后，补缺选举仍在不断获胜。但正是在那个周末，在新芬党的大会期间，还举行了一场志愿军大会。也就是说，爱尔兰志愿军（作为军事翼）开始重新调动了。许多在起义后被拘留、现在已经回家的人
been interned after the Rising and who are now home get involved in the founding of volunteer companies militarizing around the company. On top of that, the Irish Republican Brotherhood had not gone away. They had formed with Collins largely as their head, with Richard Mulcahy, who was also involved in the 1916 Rising and the man whose poem we read earlier, Thomas Ash, at its core. And they have gone around from earlier in 1917 1917 advertising for, or organizing, sorry, for the volunteers. And it's in this point, in the summer of 1917, that Thomas Ash was
开始参与志愿军连队的建立，在各地进行军事化整编。最重要的是，爱尔兰共和兄弟会并没有消失。他们重新组建了核心领导层，主要由科林斯领导，理查德·穆尔卡希（Richard Mulcahy，他也参与了1916年起义）以及我们之前朗读其诗作的托马斯·阿什（Thomas Ash）为核心。他们从1917年初开始到处为志愿军进行宣传或组织工作。正是在这个时期，即1917年夏天，托马斯·阿什
arrested for a seditious speech, that he was put in Mount Joy jail ultimately, and went on hunger strike to demand essentially prisoner of war status. And it was declined to him. And you said you would tell Tom what happened next, so what happened next? So Thomas Sash was, he's held for just under a month and he goes on hunger strike and it's this incredibly powerful moment, the idea of sort of sacrificing yourself for the cause. And he's on hunger strike for just two or three days and then they force feed him and force feeding is a, you know, it's an incredibly brutal and evasive process and basically he dies during the course of being
因煽动性言论被捕，最终被关进芒乔伊监狱（Mount Joy jail），并为争取战俘地位而绝食抗议。但他的诉求遭到拒绝。你曾说你会告诉汤姆接下来发生了什么，那么接下来发生了什么？所以托马斯·阿什被关押了不到一个月，他开始绝食抗议。这是一个极具感染力的时刻，体现了为事业自我牺牲的精神。他绝食了两三天后，狱警对他进行强行灌食。强行灌食是一种极其残酷且极具侵入性的过程，基本上，他在被
force fed. It's, you know, he's weakened, he's sick, he's starving and his death becomes this great sacrifice for the cause and then his funeral becomes a huge deal doesn't it? I mean massive turnout at his funeral of these volunteers of people who've joined the cause and the famous, maybe you read it Paul, the famous oration that is given by Michael Collins after shots are wrung out over the grave. Because it's not a long oration is it? It's one of those where Collins says after the volley of shots nothing additional remains to be said that volley which we have just heard is
强行灌食的过程中去世了。当时他已经虚弱、生病、挨饿，他的死成了为大义作出的伟大牺牲，然后他的葬礼变成了一件大事，不是吗？我的意思是，他的葬礼上出现了庞大的人群，都是这些志愿军和加入这个事业的人，还有那场著名的——也许你来读一下，保罗——迈克尔·科林斯在墓穴上方鸣枪后发表的著名悼词。因为这不是一篇很长的悼词，对吧？那是科林斯在齐射的枪声过后说道：
the only speech which it is proper to make above the grave of a dead Fenian. Yeah and so one of these kind of symbolic moments isn't it and I do think there's a sense at this point so we're in the second half of 1917 that the momentum has shifted beyond recovery, that effectively the revolutionaries have seized control of the narrative. I think they are seizing rather than seized. I don't think the momentum is entirely with them yet. I think there is a large wind in their sails and Dublin Castle is clear.
无需再多说什么，我们刚刚听到的齐射，就是在死去的芬尼亚人墓前唯一恰当的悼词。是的，这就是那种象征性的时刻，不是吗？我确实觉得在那个时候——我们正处于1917年的下半年——势头已经发生了不可逆转的转变，革命者实际上已经夺取了叙事的主导权。我认为他们正在夺取，而不是已经夺取。我不认为势头已经完全掌握在他们手中。我认为他们顺风顺水，都柏林城堡对此看得很清楚。
The leading officials are clear on this. The Thomas Ash funeral is massive. Now, it's probably one of the most most notorious things in history that the Irish love a good funeral in any point. But the political funerals in Ireland are something else entirely. And what this meant on the day was a huge organisation of volunteer strength. They basically took over the middle of Dublin, took over the middle of the city and marched the coffin
主要官员对此看得很清楚。托马斯·阿什的葬礼规模空前盛大。现在，这可能是历史上最臭名昭著的事情之一，即爱尔兰人在任何时候都喜欢办一场风光的葬礼。但爱尔兰的政治葬礼完全是另一码事。当天这意味着对志愿军力量的巨大组织。他们基本上接管了都柏林市中心，占领了市中心，护送着棺材
from beside where you're staying alongside Dublin Castle from City Hall, which they got from the city to run, lay him in state. Huge crowds come to see his body lying in state. He is then walked through the city behind a cortege with guns everywhere. There's guns being fired in the city again over his body and Dublin Castle are clear This is a huge moment and swells of people begin to join the volunteers now But poor could I also ask what also happens famously in 1917 is the Russian Revolution? Yeah, and Dublin Castle so will be the intelligence authorities there will start to frame what is happening in Irish nationalist circles as
从你住处旁边、沿着都柏林城堡旁的市政厅（他们从市里接管的市政厅）出发，将他的遗体公开停灵。大批民众前来瞻仰他的遗体。随后，棺材在葬礼队伍的簇拥下穿过城市，到处都是枪支。城里再次为他的遗体鸣枪，都柏林城堡看得清清楚楚：这是一个巨大的时刻，成群结队的人现在开始加入志愿军。但是保罗，我也想问，1917年还发生了哪件著名的历史事件？俄罗斯革命吗？是的，都柏林城堡的情报当局开始将爱尔兰民族主义圈子里发生的事情定性为
Informed by Bolshevism and is that serving to kind of raise alarm bells back in London? Where of course the government is still focused on winning the war it really isn't Tom There's things being thrown left and right and it's the words are there but what's happening in Ireland is seen to be manageable Compared to what's happening on the Western front. Everything is suborn to the war and everything, by the way, has been suborn to get America into the war and on their side. So Irish policy is almost framed with the idea of not upsetting Irish America too much to the point that it will that will keep the President Wilson of America out of the war. So America much more important than Russia in the British. Enormously.
受布尔什维克主义影响，这是否开始在伦敦敲响警钟？当然，那里的政府依然专注于赢得战争……其实并没有，汤姆。各种事情层出不穷，虽然那些词汇被提及了，但与西线战场上发生的事情相比，爱尔兰发生的事情被认为是可控的。一切都服从于战争，顺便说一句，一切都服从于让美国参战并站在他们这一边。因此，爱尔兰政策的制定几乎是为了避免过度惹恼爱尔兰裔美国人，以免把美国总统威尔逊气得不肯参战。所以对英国人来说，美国比俄罗斯重要得多。极其重要。
So let's come to a massive, a game changing moment, a real watershed in this story. So Britain had introduced conscription in 1916 and it was an issue that had effectively split the liberal movement, the liberal party. A lot of liberals, kind of Asquithian liberals, were horrified by the idea of conscription. They thought, you know, it's a complete attack on civil liberties and whatnot. But it had been introduced in Britain, but not in Ireland, because they recognized that in Ireland it would be incendiary to force people to fight for king and country. And there'd been lots of talk about it. And then in 1918, the picture
那么，让我们谈谈一个巨大的、具有游戏规则改变意义的时刻，这个故事中的一个真正的分水岭。英国在1916年引入了征兵制，这个问题实际上导致了自由党运动、自由党的分裂。许多自由党人——类似于阿斯奎斯派的自由党人——对征兵制的想法感到惊恐。他们认为，这完全是对公民自由等的攻击。但它已经在英国本土推行，却没有在爱尔兰推行，因为他们认识到，在爱尔兰强迫人们为国王和国家而战将会具有煽动性。当时有很多关于这方面的讨论。然后到了1918年，局势又发生了变化。
completely changes. and here we go back to the importance of the First World War. The Germans launch their last throw, Ludendorff's last throw, the spring offensive, they look like they're going to get through all the way to Paris. It looks like the war is going to be lost for the Allies. And at that point, the Tories in particular in Britain say to Lloyd George, come on mate, this is ridiculous that we're not conscripting men in Ireland when we're already doing it in Britain. We have to do it in Ireland as well because it just looks terrible to people in Britain that we're not doing it. And of course as we know this is an absolute own goal.
完全改变了。我们现在回过头来看第一次世界大战的重要性。德国人发起了他们的最后孤注一掷，鲁登endorff的最后孤注一掷，春季攻势，他们看起来要一路打到巴黎。同盟国似乎要输掉这场战争了。就在那时，英国的保守党人特别对劳埃德·乔治说，老兄，别闹了，我们在英国已经在征兵了，却不在爱尔兰征兵，这太荒谬了。我们也必须在爱尔兰征兵，因为在英国人看来，我们不这样做实在太难看了。当然，正如我们所知，这是一个绝对的乌龙球。
I mean, it's like Lloyd George is taking a rifle and aiming it at his foot. The RSG secretary famously says you might as well recruit Germans. So why is it so so conscription is is a colossal disaster isn't it for the cause of moderate nationalism as well as unionism I guess. It is a disaster on every front for people who wish for the union to be maintained, for the government. It was a humiliating moment for the government. It was a humiliating moment for the government. It was a disaster for the Irish parliamentary party, moderate nationalism, which was already under threat from Sinn Fein,
我的意思是，这就好比劳埃德·乔治拿起一支步枪瞄准了自己的脚。皇家爱尔兰宪兵队（RIC）秘书曾有一句名言：你不如直接去招募德国人。所以，为什么——所以征兵绝对是一个巨大的灾难，对温和民族主义以及工会主义事业来说都是如此，我想是的。这对那些希望维持联邦的人、对政府来说，在各个方面都是一场灾难。这是政府的一个屈辱时刻。这是爱尔兰议会党——温和民族主义的一场灾难，当时它已经受到新芬党的威胁，
but was destroyed by what happens next. And what happened next was, first of all, the Irish parliamentary party walked out of the House of Commons where it had still had its seats led by John Dylan. John Rendon at this stage was dead. He had died earlier in 1918. His brother Willie, also an MP, had died fighting for the British army. So again, so this is a man whose life ended coming so close to the ultimate success that had eluded Parnell, eluded Daniel O'Connell. And this was a man who was on the cusp when
但却被接下来发生的事情彻底摧毁了。接下来的事情是，首先，由约翰·狄龙率领的爱尔兰议会党走出了下议院，他们当时在那里仍有席位。约翰·雷德蒙在这个时候已经去世了。他在1918年早些时候去世了。他的弟弟威利，也是一名议员，在为英国军队作战时牺牲了。所以，再次说明，这是一个生命即将迎来巨大成功的人，这个成功曾与帕内尔、丹尼尔·奥康奈尔失之交臂。这是一个正处于巅峰的人，当
the war started of absolute success. Now the war is going on. He dies in pain. His brother is dead and now his party is taken over by John Dylan, leader of the party in Dublin and he walks out of the House of Commons. Following the example of Sinn Féin. Yeah, so the Irish parliamentary party, well the Irish parliamentary party had successfully resisted the implementation of conscription in Ireland before then. But everything that the Irish parliamentary party had stood for was gone in that moment. They come home and they're now on a platform in meetings with Sinn Féin, who they
战争爆发时，他本有望取得绝对的成功。现在战争还在继续。他在痛苦中死去。他的弟弟死了，现在他的党派由党内驻都柏林领袖约翰·狄龙接管，他走出了下议院。效仿了新芬党的榜样。是的，所以爱尔兰议会党——嗯，在此之前，爱尔兰议会党曾成功抵制了征兵制在爱尔兰的实施。但爱尔兰议会党曾经代表的一切在那一刻都烟消云散了。他们回到家，现在与新芬党人同台开会，而这些新芬党人
would have previously looked on as corner boys and a rabble to some extent. And Catholic bishops are there as well. So this is the respectability of the Catholic Church. And Tom, you've made the point about how central religion was to society a hundred years ago, much more so than now, for Catholic bishops to be sharing with Republicans, some of whom had previously been excommunicated from the church and with moderate nationalism. And Sinn Féin is saying, we told you so.
他们以前在某种程度上看作是街头流氓和乌合之众。天主教为主的主教们也在场。所以这是天主教教会的威望。汤姆，你曾指出宗教在一百年前对社会是多么核心，比现在重要得多，天主教主教们竟然与共和党人——其中一些人以前曾被教会开除——以及温和民族主义者共享一个平台。而新芬党则在说，我们早就告诉过你们了。
Yeah. And they have the power, they run now and the conscription, they managed to create a conscription where it should be said, by the way, that the Labour movement and the Labour party was huge in this as well, because of the general strikes that were run during this period, which basically showed the government that this wasn't going to be workable. You were going to need to bring 100,000 soldiers here to get people to conscript. I mean just to kind of stick up for Lloyd George. I mean he and you've been saying this throughout
是的。而且他们掌握着权力和运转，现在有了征兵，顺便说一句，劳工运动和工党在这其中也发挥了巨大作用，因为这一时期举行的总罢工，基本上向政府表明这是行不通的。你需要把十万名士兵带到这里来强迫人们服兵役。我的意思是，就当作是为劳埃德·乔治说句公道话吧。我的意思是，他和你在整个过程中一直在说的观点一样
that the focus of the British government is on the Western Front and Lloyd George is staring down the barrel of defeat. So again he must be thinking you know I've got to throw everything at this and he actually compares himself to Lincoln, doesn't he? But he's also, the reason why George is doing this is not just because of the military situation, it's because of his own political situation. He relies on conservative support and the Conservatives effectively are saying to him, if you don't do this, we'll withdraw support because we think it's a matter of principle that Ireland is treated the same as Britain.
英国政府的焦点在西线，而劳埃德·乔治正面对着失败的枪口。所以再次说明，他一定在想，你知道的，我必须把一切都押在这上面，他甚至把自己比作林肯，不是吗？但他也，乔治这样做的原因不仅是因为军事形势，还因为他自己的政治形势。他依赖保守党的支持，而保守党实际上在对他说，如果你不这样做，我们就会撤回支持，因为我们认为按照原则，爱尔兰应该受到与英国相同的对待。
He was not someone who had an instinctive connection or sympathy with the Irish cause in any shape or form. He didn't really see why Ireland should be different than Wales. Well this is actually a really interesting thing with Lloyd George. His Welshness actually works against, because he says come on we're cults too and we have our own differences with the English so why can't you be just like us? Yes and he was a part of that strain also of English society or Welsh society or British society, which was anti-Catholic.
他并不是那种对爱尔兰事业有任何形式的本能联系或同情的人。他真的不明白为什么爱尔兰应该和威尔士有什么不同。嗯，这其实是劳埃德·乔治一个非常有趣的地方。他的威尔士身份实际上对他的立场产生了反作用，因为他说，得了吧，我们也是凯尔特人，我们与英格兰人也有我们自己的分歧，所以你们为什么不能就像我们一样呢？是的，他也是英国社会、威尔士社会或英国社会中那种反天主教情绪的一部分。
He had kind of averged, depending on who you were talking to, in that area between distaste and distrust, or blind hatred, depending on which way you go, not necessarily like George, but that community all told. We're approaching the end of the episode. What's obviously happened is the conscription crisis has turbocharged, has accelerated a process that was already underway, which is radicalization. So you get a massive influx, don't you, into people signing pledges and petitions, they're joining Sinn Fein, young men, well we will talk about this in the next episode, what kind of people are joining the paramilitary groups.
他那种态度，取决于你和谁谈论，介于厌恶和不信任之间，或者盲目的仇恨，取决于你倾向于哪种看法，不一定是指乔治个人，而是整个那个群体。我们正接近这一集的尾声。显而易见发生的事情是，征兵危机极大地推动、加速了一个已经在进行中的进程，那就是激进化。所以你会发现大量的人签署保证书和请愿书，他们加入新芬党，年轻人——嗯，我们将在下一集讨论这个问题，什么样的人正在加入准军事组织。
Young men are joining the Irish volunteers. And the government's really lost control of the story. What do, so you're the Irish man and woman in the street, if we can massively simplify and generalize, what do they think at this stage? Is it possible to say or is there a sort of general picture? How much does the propaganda matter in changing their outlook? I think the propaganda does matter because you are basically now faced with a movement which is placing a very straightforward proposition in front of a population. And it is this,
年轻人正在加入爱尔兰志愿军。政府真的失去了对局势的控制。那么，如果你是街头普通的爱尔兰男人和女人，如果我们能大幅简化和概括的话，他们在这个阶段是怎么想的？这可以说清楚吗，还是有一种大致的图景？宣传在改变他们的观点方面有多大作用？我认为宣传确实很重要，因为你现在基本上面对的是一个运动，它正在向民众提出一个非常直接的主张。它是这样的，
we are either patriots fighting the regime or we are complicit in its tyranny. And there's a new mass movement now, which is kind of a populist national movement. It's changed from that kind of ginger groups of Republicans or radicals or feminists or socialists. And it's got broad ideas of patriotism now, which are hung always on kind of ideas of the ballads that are being sung or the flags that are being flown or a broad suede of program where I look at the agrarian program. It wasn't just that Ireland were going to redistribute large farms to the people who tend and farm with them or the tenant farmers would get their farms made larger.
我们要么是与政权抗争的爱国者，要么就是其暴政的共犯。现在出现了一个新的群众运动，它有点像民粹主义的民族运动。它已经从那种孤立的共和党人、激进分子、女权主义者或社会主义者的边缘小团体转变成了大众运动。它现在拥有广泛的爱国主义理念，这些理念总是与传唱的民谣、飘扬的旗语或涵盖土地改革方案的广泛纲领挂钩。这不仅仅是爱尔兰要将大农场重新分配给那些在上面耕作的农民，或者让佃农的农场变得更大。
People who are land laborers were going to be given farms as well. I mean, they basically planned that we were going to expand the landmass of the island so much were they were they going to do. But that's what you do, isn't it? When you're trying to win any argument and that's what they went for. And so the British government feel that they're facing a hydra. And when faced with a hydra, the temptation is to try and cut off the heads. And so this is what they do in the summer of 1918,
土地劳工也将获得农场。我的意思是，他们基本上计划要极大地扩大这个岛屿的耕地面积，他们当时真的是这么打算的。但当你试图赢得任何辩论时，你就是会这样做，而这就是他们所选择的途径。因此，英国政府觉得他们正在面对一头九头蛇。而面对九头蛇时，人们的本能就是试图砍掉它的头。所以这就是他们在1918年夏天所做的事情，
when essentially they manufacture a plot that comes to be known as the German plot. The idea that the heads, basically all the people they want to intern are complicit with the Germans, and it's done on very, very sketchy information, but it's enough for them to start arresting people that they want to have in prison rather than out on the streets. The information is so sketchy that it's enough for them to start arresting people that they want to have in prison rather than out on the streets. The information is so sketchy that it's based on that members of the British cabinet around it are kind of going, they're utterly disbelieving of it.
当时他们基本上炮制了一个后来被称为“德国阴谋”的事件。他们构想出这样一个观点：这些头目，也就是他们想要关押的所有人，都在勾结德国人，这是在非常非常粗略的情报基础上完成的，但对他们来说已经足够了，可以开始逮捕那些他们希望关在监狱里而不是让他们留在街上的人。这些情报非常粗略，甚至连英国内阁周围的一些成员听说了都在摇头，他们对此完全不相信。
But but Lloyd George is humiliated and they're bent on making a statement. So it hangs around the fact that an Irishman who had been in the British Army had been captured, had been a POW in Germany, tried to be recruited to Casemans cause to come back over here. He was found in a boat off County Clare on his own. So wild rumours then begin to spread of a German plot and 73 leaders of Sinn Fein were arrested, including De Valera and Griffiths. But Michael Collins knew what was going to happen. And so did Richard Mulcahy because they already had spies deep within the British system, both in Dublin Castle and in its military forces, and they were able to tip people off. Now, some of the Sinn Fein leaders were more than happy to be arrested because, of course, there is an enormous value in the publicity of it,
但劳埃德·乔治受到了羞辱，他们决心要表明立场。这件事源于一个曾加入英国军队的爱尔兰人，他曾在德国被俘，成为战俘，并被试图招募以加入凯斯曼的事业回到这里来。他被发现独自一人在一艘位于克莱尔郡海岸外的船上。于是，关于德国阴谋的野蛮谣言开始四处流传，73名新芬党领导人被捕，其中包括德瓦莱拉和格里菲斯。但迈克尔·柯林斯知道将要发生什么。理查德·穆尔卡西也是如此，因为他们在英国系统内部——无论是在都柏林城堡还是在其军事力量中——都安插了深度的间谍，他们能够提前通风报信。现在，一些新芬党领导人甚至很高兴被捕，因为当然，这能带来巨大的宣传价值，
but Collins and Mulcahy slipped away. And Dublin Castle don't even have photographs of Collins, so they don't know what he looks like. But of course they don't have photographs of, they have very few photographs. This is an age when you don't even have photographs of Collins, so they don't know what he looks like. But of course they don't have photographs of, they have very few photographs. This is an age when you don't have many photographs of people. But you can, the strategy can either be you put yourself centre and you take your martyrdom, you go to prison, or you slip into the shadows and you preserve your mystique as the master
但柯林斯和穆尔卡西溜走了。都柏林城堡甚至没有柯林斯的照片，所以他们不知道他长什么样。当然，他们没有照片，他们几乎没有照片。这是一个连柯林斯的照片都没有的时代，所以他们不知道他长什么样。当然，他们没有照片，他们几乎没有照片。这是一个人们没有多少照片的时代。但你可以，策略要么是让自己成为中心并承担你的殉道，进监狱，要么是融入阴影，保持你作为间谍大师的神秘感，而这正是柯林斯所做的。关于这件事，最令人惊奇的是在关于1916年起义调查委员会的报告中，那份报告——这是一份极好的文件，人们可以在网上找到，共16页，必须阅读，因为它实在是太离奇了。总督被免除了所有责任。一切责任都被推给了都柏林城堡的首席秘书奥古斯丁·比尔和其次secretary马修·内坦。他们说警察和军队表现得极其出色。他们没有做错任何事。
of spies, which is what Collins does. And the amazing thing about this is in the report, the Commission of Investigation into the rising of 1916, the report was, it's a fantastic document which people can find online at 16 pages and must be read because it's so bizarre. The Lord Lieutenant is excused of all blame. Everything is placed on Dublin Castle's Chief Secretary, Augustin Burrell, and its undersecretary, Matthew Natan. And they say there was the police and the military were brilliant. They done nothing wrong.
他们报告了当时发生的一切。他们的情报真的很好。但一次又一次的事实证明，实际情况恰恰相反。在实行拘留时被证明如此，在“德国阴谋”中再次被证明如此。所以这是一个真正摇摇欲坠的国家。那么在这一点上，就在我们进入1918年底的大选之前，在这一点上，你认为英国人的游戏其实已经结束了吗？你认为对他们来说
They told everything what happened on that. Their intelligence was really good. And time and time again, it's revealed the opposite is the case. It was proven to be so when it came to internment, it was proven to be so again in the German plot. So this is a state which is really creaking. So at this point, just before we move into the election at the end of 1918, at this point do you think the game is actually already up for the British? Do you think there's
还有回旋的余地吗？毫无疑问，必须建立某种形式的自治议会。问题是这个议会将获得多少权力，以及这是否需要通过战争来解决，或者给予自治领地位等，而这似乎并不在议程上。与此同时，与此同时，还有阿尔斯特的问题，这个问题没有被任何人解决，英国人没有解决，也没有被没有计划的爱尔兰民族主义者解决。好吧。因此，在1918年11月，战争结束了，德国的攻势已经减弱并平息，德国人崩溃了，到处都在举行盛大的庆祝活动，战争结束了，一个月后，即1918年12月13日，联合王国终于迎来了大选，
any way back for them? There is no doubt that there has to be a Home Rule Parliament of some description. The question is how much power that parliament is going to get and is it going to take war or the giving of dominion status, for example, which doesn't seem to be on the agenda. And all the while, all the while, there is the problem of Ulster, which has not been resolved by anybody, not by the British and not by Irish nationalists who don't have a plan. Right. So November 1918, the war ends, the German offensive has petered out, the Germans have collapsed, there are great celebrations, the war is over, and a month later on the 13th of December 1918, at last the United Kingdom goes to the polls
实际上你看到的是两场独立的选举在进行，一场在大不列颠，一场在爱尔兰。由于各种原因，这是一场具有里程碑意义的选举。所有21岁以上的男性现在都可以投票，30岁以上的女性也可以投票。所以爱尔兰的选民人数达到了多少？增加了一倍以上。我认为，汤姆，多米尼克，它增加了两倍，从70万激增到近200万。大约十分之七的人是第一次投票。第一次。所以根本无法预测他们会怎么投票。这场选举的巨大赢家是新芬党，他们的竞选纲领是，这是一个极其出色的纲领，
and effectively you've got two separate elections going on, one in Great Britain and one in Ireland. And this is a landmark election for all kinds of reasons. All men over the age of 21 can now vote, all the women over the age of 30. So the electorate in Ireland has what? More than doubled. It's trebled, I think, Tom. Dominic has trebled from 700,000 to almost 2 million. And something like seven out of 10 people are voting for the first time. For the first time. So it's impossible to predict how they'll vote. And the big winners of this are Sinn Fein and their manifesto is, it's a brilliant manifesto
因为它既模棱两可又非常明确，因为他们基本上有三大目标，对吧？给我们讲讲他们的目标。所以他们的三大目标是建立一个独立的——给我们讲讲他们的目标。所以他们的三大目标是建立一个独立的爱尔兰共和国。在此之后有一句非常精彩的话，对接下来我们将要在下一集中讨论的独立战争具有极其重要的意义。它说我们将通过一切可用之手段建立一个独立的爱尔兰共和国，以削弱英国通过军事力量或其他方式将爱尔兰置于其统治之下的权力。这就是用来合法化独立战争的那句话。它说这得到了
because it's simultaneously vague but also very clear because they have basically three big goals, don't they? Talk us through their goals. So their three big goals are to establish an independent Focus through their goals. So there are three big goals are to establish an independent Irish Republic. And there was a brilliant phrase after this, which is hugely important for what happens next in the War of Independence, which we'll be talking about in the next episode. It says we will establish an independent Irish Republic by any and every means available to render impotent the power of England to hold Ireland in subjection by military force or otherwise. That's the phrase that is used to legitimize a war of independence. It says it has the support of
民调显示的公众支持。所以它的第一个计划是建立一个独立的爱尔兰共和国。它的第二个计划是退出下议院。所以他们认为他们将赢得80个席位。爱尔兰有一百多个席位。他们认为他们将在这场选举中赢得80个席位。他们说，我们不去了。我们将在这里建立我们自己的议会。第三点极其重要。这在当时的报纸上引起了巨大反响，我认为它在某种程度上被人们忽略了，那就是巴黎和平会议的重要性。新芬党人说，巴黎和平会议，我们要去巴黎。威尔逊有他的十四点原则。你们刚刚为小比利时打了一场仗。
the public as given by the polls on it. So its first plan is to establish an independent Irish Republic. Its second plan is to withdraw from the House of Commons. So they think they're going to win 80 seats. There's a hundred odd seats in Ireland. They think they're going to win 80 seats in this election. And they say, we're not going. We're going to establish our own parliament here. And the third point is hugely important. And this is massive in the papers at the time. And I think it's been lost a little bit in it is the importance of the Paris Peace Conference. The Paris Peace Conference, Sinn Fein said, we are going to Paris. Wilson has his 14 points. You've just fought a war for little Belgium.
是的。你们一直在谈论小国的权利。所以我们是一个小国，我们是一个小国家。我们要去巴黎。我们要去巴黎争取一个席位，并且我们要利用美国爱尔兰游说团体的权势和影响力，来让威尔逊支持我们，从而在那个谈判桌上获得一个席位，我们将会独立。
Yeah. You've talked about the rights of small nations. So we're a small nation. We're a small country. We're going to Paris. We're going to get a seat in Paris and we're going to use our American leverage because of the power and potency of the Irish American lobby to get Wilson to support us to get a seat at that table and we will be independent.
好的，所以结果是新芬党赢得了73个席位，统一派赢得了26个席位，而温和派残存的力量——爱尔兰议会党，只剩下可怜的6个席位。所以我的意思是，这确实是爱尔兰政治的一场革命，对吧？这太巨大了，简直是一次彻底的横扫。但这种横扫在此之前就已经在酝酿中了。当新芬党预测自己能赢得80席时，他们并不是盲目行事。这是一个时代已经结束的老朽政党。爱尔兰议会党为之奋斗的一切。而且他们赢了，他们赢得了自治权，只是没能将其付诸实施。他们曾说他们长期阻止了征兵制进入爱尔兰，
Right so the results Sinn Fein win 73 seats the Unionists win 26 and what's left of the moderates the Irish Parliamentary Party they're reduced to just six seats so I mean this is really a revolution in Irish politics isn't it? It's enormous and it's complete wipeout. But the wipeout was on the way beforehand. When Sinn Fein predicted 80 seats it wasn't blind in what they were doing. This was an aging party whose time was done. Everything the Irish parliamentary party had fought for. And won, they'd won Home Rule, they just hadn't got it implemented. They had said that they had stopped conscription coming in for long periods,
但雷德蒙曾呼吁征兵，所以他们对此一点好处也没捞到。他们曾主张应该提前释放英国监狱里的爱尔兰囚犯，但他们自己并没有去关。他们现在站在了囚犯的对立面，许多人直接退休了。在全国的大片地区，他们在过去40年里甚至在选举中都没有遇到过竞争对手。所以他们没有对抗新芬党的机器。因此，这是一次彻底的权力交替。我的意思是，人们几乎可以说是发生了一场革命。我想对于爱尔兰人民来说，问题在于接下来去向何方，
but Redmond had called for recruitment, so they got no good out of that at all. They said that they had argued that the prisoners should be released early from prison in England, but they weren't the prisoners themselves. They were standing against the prisoners now and loads of them just retired. And in large swathes of the country, they had not been opposed in elections for 40 years. So they didn't have a machine to fight back against Sinn Fein. So it's a complete changing of the guard. I mean, one might almost say a revolution. And I suppose for people in Ireland, there's the question of where next,
这个国家将如何被治理，未来是什么样的，而在英国，则有一种前景：即便西线战场上大炮的轰鸣声正渐渐归于沉寂，战争的阴云可能正在爱尔兰和联合王国上空聚集。因此，如果人们想知道接下来会发生什么，他们可以加入我们自己的革命兄弟会——“历史的其余部分”俱乐部，正如保罗无疑知道的那样，你可以在therestishistory.com上做到这一点。但我们将与保罗一起回归，继续讲述这个惊心动魄的故事的下一部分——爱尔兰独立战争。再见。再见。
how is the state going to be governed, what's the future and in Britain there's the prospect that even as the guns, the crumping of the guns are falling silent on the Western Front, storm clouds of war may be gathering over Ireland and over the United Kingdom. So if people want to find out what happens next, they could join our own revolutionary brotherhood, the Rest His History Club, and as Paul undoubtedly knows, you can do that at therestishistory.com. But we'll be back with Paul for the next installment of this thrilling story with the Irish War of Independence. Goodbye. Goodbye.
再见。再见。再见。大家好，这是我们在中场休息时提到的《大白鲨》片段。你可以在 therestisentertainment.com 上免费收听整集节目。而且这个时候连演员都还没定好。这部电影的选角简直拖到了最后一刻。离原定开机日期还有九天时，三个主要角色中的两个——昆特和胡珀——在九天前都还没定下来。所以每个人都准备好了。整个剧组都准备好出发了。你知道的，整个摄制组。这两个角色最终在电影中分别由罗伯特·肖和理查德·德莱弗斯饰演。这两个
Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye. Hey everyone, here's that Jaws clip that we mentioned during the break. You can listen to the whole episode for free on therestisentertainment.com. There's no cast at this point as well. The cast is so last minute for this. It was nine days before principal photography was due to start. Two of the three main parts, Quint and Hooper, still hadn't been cast nine days before. So everyone's ready. Everyone's ready to go. You know, the whole unit. Who were eventually played by Robert Shaw and Richard Rophers in the movie. And those
人之间有着巨大的矛盾。他们考虑过的人选实在太多了。至于布罗迪这个角色，实际上由罗伊·施耐德饰演，这是一次精彩绝伦的表演。他的表现如此出色，如此身不由己，就像每一个普通人一样。是的。我的意思是，其他被考虑过的人选还有保罗·纽曼、查尔顿·赫斯顿、罗伯特·杜瓦尔、吉恩·哈克曼。显然最后这两个人是完全能演好的。是的。所以我觉得查尔顿·赫斯顿当时极度渴望参演。而斯皮尔伯格，同样地，你
two have a massive feud. There were so many other different people that they considered. Now Brody, who was actually played by Roy Scheider, it's a brilliant performance. He's so sort of, it's an amazing performance. So put upon and like every man. Yeah. I mean, the other people considered were Paul Newman, Charlton Heston, Robert DeVille, Gene Hatman. Like definitely the last two of those could have done it. Yeah. So I think Charlton Heston was desperate to be in it. And Spielberg, again, you know
知道吗，他从一开始就很聪明，斯皮尔伯格。他说，想想查尔顿·赫斯顿吧，他的名气太大了。为什么他名气太大？因为你知道查尔顿·赫斯顿总是会赢。这就是问题所在。你知道查尔顿·赫斯顿会击败那条鲨鱼。你根本不知道罗伊·施耐德会怎么做。你就是不知道。所以这真的很重要。罗伊·施耐德有一种随时可能被吃掉的面相。绝对会被吃掉。看起来绝对会被吃掉。你会觉得，是的，我能想象得到。
what, he was smart right from the beginning, Spielberg. He said, think about Charlton Heston, he's too big a star. Why is he too big? Because you know Charlton Heston always wins. That's the problem. You know Charlton Heston is going to defeat the shark. You don't know what Roy Scheider is going to do. You just don't know. So it's really important. Roy Scheider has the look of a man who could be eaten. Definitely be eaten. Who could definitely be eaten. You'd be like, yeah, I can see it.
我不知道他的经纪人会不会说他会出演，但他不能被吃掉。他绝对会被吃掉。查尔顿·赫斯顿会吃掉鲨鱼。查尔顿·赫斯顿会吃掉鲨鱼。又一个适合这本书的好书名。罗伊·施耐德其实是在一个派对上听到史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格谈论这个的，当时史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格说他有一个想法，关于如何让鲨鱼跳上一艘船。
I don't know if his agent is going to be saying he's going to be in it, but he can't be eaten. He could definitely be eaten. Charlton Heston eats sharks. Charlton Heston eats sharks. Again, another great title for the book. Roy Scheider actually heard Steven Spielberg talking about it at a party and Steven Spielberg was saying he'd had this idea for how he could get the shark to jump onto a boat.
我想，我很想参演那部电影。听起来真不错。我喜欢这个小伙子。他说，我想参演这部电影。总之。顺便说一句，查尔顿·赫斯顿发誓从此再也不和斯皮尔伯格合作了。大家好。你们居然还在。
I thought, I'd like to be in that movie. That sounds good. I like this kid. And he said, I would like to be in this movie. Anyway. Charlton Heston, by the way, vowed never to work with Spielberg after that. Hi everybody. You're still here.
节目都到尾声了，我对你们的执着深表钦佩。不过听着，我有个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。你们有时会听这些节目里的广告吗？你们有时会想，你知道吗？我希望这个播客的听众们听的是关于我的品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你有过这种想法，当然只有一种方法能知道那会是什么感觉。你可以打断广告的连续播放。你可以成为下一个汇丰尊贵理财（HSBC Premier）或许多在《历史的其余部分》上投放过广告的杰出公司之一。你可以把你的品牌
Right at the end of the episode, I'm very impressed by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes? And do you sometimes think, do you know what? I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that, there is of course any one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC premiere or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest is history. And you could put your brand
展示给数百万志同道合的听众，只需在《历史的其余部分》以及高挂网（Goalhanger Network）的其他节目上投放广告。现在你可能会想，我不知道什么是高挂网。高挂网正是打造这个节目的公司。如果你正打算提升你的品牌的价值，高挂网非常乐意听到你的声音。你可以立即访问 Goalhanger.com 注册你的意愿，或者是你公司的意愿。网址是 Goal，即 G-O-A-L，Hanger，即 H-A-N-G-E-R，点 com。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
in front of millions of like-minded listeners by advertising on The Rest is History and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest or indeed your company's interest by going to Goalhanger.com right now. And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, Hanga, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在数百万志同道合的听众面前，通过在《历史的剩余》以及高汉格网络的其他节目上进行广告投放来宣传您的品牌。现在您可能在想，我不知道什么是高汉格网络。高汉格正是制作本节目的公司。如果您正打算提升品牌价值，高汉格非常期待听到您的声音。您现在就可以访问 Goalhanger.com 登记您或您公司的意向。网址是 Goal，G-O-A-L，Hanga，H-A-N-G-E-R，点 com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。